[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes officiellement lancé à
l'automne aux noms leblanc pour
poursuivre notre lancée avec toi c'est
seulement la pratique consommateurs qui
peuvent remplacer justin trudeau qui
pouvait se battre pour vous c'est le npd
dumas korpi votre confiance jamais
honoré regretté le vote avait le plus de
pouvoir c'est un beau teint
les autres partis ont de bonnes raisons
d'avoir peur de nous les canadiens vont
faire un choix
quelle direction ils veulent prendre
pour le pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en direct du musée canadien de
l'histoire à gatineau le partenariat
canadien pour la production des débats
vous présente le débat des chefs 2019
voici patrice roy bonsoir bienvenue à ce
débat des chefs
madame messieurs les chefs bonsoir à
vous vos places sur la scène et l'ordre
de parole ont été déterminées au hasard
cinq thèmes seront abordés ce soir
chaque thème sera lancé par une question
d'un citoyen en direct après la réponse
des chefs
il y aura deux confrontations à 3 puis
des questions en rafale de journalistes
invités
ce débat sera suivi par des citoyens ici
au musée de l'histoire à gatineau
on vous remercie messieurs dames d'être
ici et partout à travers le pays des
rassemblements ont été organisés
c'est le dernier débat de cette campagne
vous le savez je compte sur vous madame
messieurs les chefs pour nous donner des
réponses claires et surtout ne pas tous
parler en même temps j'y verrai
d'ailleurs vous verrez parfois
apparaître à l'écran le temps de parole
cumulatif des chefs
madame messieurs bon débat
[Musique]
premier thème environnement et énergie
et nous commençons ce thème de trois
rivières ce soir avec une question
d'elisabeth darveau madame darveau
bonsoir à vous ben ça alors madame d'un
volet chef vous écoute votre question
dans une ère où nous sommes de plus en
plus touchés par la cause
environnementale et où l'onu a déclaré
l'urgence climatique
il devient urgent de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour contrer
cette crise
ma question est la suivante sachant que
si nous n'agissons pas maintenant nous
atteindrons le point de non retour
quel premier changement concret comptez
vous faire pour protéger l'environnement
merci madame darveau première réponse
justin trudeau
merci elizabeth pour pour votre question
fait c'est une question qu'on entend à
travers le pays depuis plusieurs
semaines au sillonnent le pays pour
parler aux gens qui justement nous
disent l'avenir de leurs enfants
l'avenir de l'environnement les plats
lutte contre les changements climatiques
c'est essentiel et on a beaucoup fait
sur 4 ha mais on doit continuer et on
doit pouvoir tenir tête contre ces
conservateurs comme john kani tom ford
et les pétrolières qui les appuient pour
pouvoir justement continuer de lutter
contre les changements climatiques y
bâtir un monde meilleur
c'est pour ça que le choix que vous
faites ce soir est si important mais
pour soi aussi
j'ai confiance dans les canadiens j'ai
confiance dans les prochaines étapes
qu'on va entamer ensemble
merci monsieur trudeau monsieur bernier
bonsoir les autres partis vous disent
qu'ils vont atteindre les cibles de
l'entente de paris mais ils ne pourront
pas les atteindre puisqu'il faut imposer
une taxe sur le carbone de 300 dollars
la tonne pour ce faire et ils ne le font
pas et où s'ils disent qu'ils vont
sauver le monde sauver le climat
mais comme vous savez les émissions
globales du canada représente seulement
2,6 pour cent des émissions totales
nous au parti populaire on veut se
concentrer sur des gestes concrets pour
l'environnement s'assurer que nos eaux
soit dépollué notre sol notre ère et je
pense qu'on peut réinvestir pour
protéger réellement l'environnement et
pas être hypocrite comme les leaders ici
autour de moi qui disent tout faire pour
aider les changements climatiques mais
dans le fond
non pas de solution monsieur c'est un
merci elizabeth
c'est vraiment gros enjeu je sais qu'au
québec on a eu des inondations sévère on
a eu des feux de forêt c'est vraiment un
impact réel qu'on fait face à ce moment
on a eu des milliers d enfants dans les
roues dont ce qu'on propose deux
maintenant pas comme si le trou d'eau
qui a acheté un pipeline
on veut annuler tout de suite tu des
subventions pétrolia s'assure une aide à
bon peut prendre tout de suite et on
peut réinvestir l'argent dans l'énergie
renouvelable dans l'énergie propre
aussi on veut réinvestir massivement
dans le transport en commun
on peut agir c'est un question est
d'avoir le courage on a le courage merci
monsieur singh monsieur oui
l'environnement c'est un des enjeux
central de cette campagne et comme père
de cinq enfants
je veux assurer que nous lasse les
prochaines générations une environnement
plus propre que nous avons hérité mais
malgré ce qui prétend justin trudeau sur
sept dossiers
son plan est un échec une des premières
décisions qu'il a prises comme des
premiers mais c'est d'autoriser de
déversement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eaux usées dans notre fleuve
mon plan va mettre fin au déversement
d'eaux usées parce que nous sommes en
merci monsieur cher monsieur blanchet
mais bien le bonsoir merci de nous
recevoir chez vous encore ce soir
il ya certainement beaucoup de mesures
qui doivent être prises je vous
emmènerai quelques-unes je pense que le
parlement devrait par le biais d'une loi
un peu comme le suggère monsieur singh
sur l'intention faire en sorte que on
cesse immédiatement toute espèce de
subventions aux industries pétrolières
c'est autour de 10 milliards par année
au total selon une étude d'équiterre
2018 ça vous dire quelque chose monsieur
trudeau et un autre loi pourrait faire
en sorte de contrainte de contraindre le
canada a respecté ses cibles parce que
pour l'instant les sites de 2009 de
monsieur scheer sont devenus les cibles
de monsieur trudeau et rien n'a été fait
pour les atteindre
il ya des mesures incitatives en termes
d'électrification des transports qui
peuvent être faites en laissant
d'ailleurs si le succès tout en vous
aviez madame mais en terminant
merci c'est vrai
sacrément ce que vous avez dit nous
sommes maintenant trop proche à un point
de non retour
on doit éviter le pire mais annoncé
seulement les verts qui a un programme
qui a aligné avec les scientifiques du
giec mais on doit travailler ensemble
pour nous renverser essentiel de mettre
sur pied aguer cabinet de guerre comme
dans le deuxième guerre mondiale de
faire les choses ensemble parce qu'on
doit éliminer les dépendances
mj fossiles et en même temps être changé
notre économie vers du nez comme hier
merci madame mais madame d'art vous
trois rivières j'espère que vous êtes
éclairé en tout cas c'est les réponses
qu'ils vous ont donnés merci beaucoup de
votre participation s'est apprécié merci
merci à vous alors premier trio première
confrontation à 3 il y aura madame et
monsieur trudeau et monsieur blanchet en
jeu depuis kyoto sehili à 30,1 les
policiers promettent de diminuer les gaz
à effet de serre pour atteindre les
cibles de paris le directeur
parlementaire du budget estime que la
taxe sur le carbone qui est de 20 $
actuellement la tonne doit grimper à 102
dollars d'ici quelques années ça pour
être très concret pour les gens la
maison c'est 23 sous de plus pour un
litre d'essence
monsieur blanchet vous êtes d'accord
avec le sang de madame et vous proposer
200 vous monsieur trudeau est ce que
vous attendez après les élections pour
afficher votre prix non monsieur roy on
a un plan pour monter ce prix là jusqu'à
50 dollars la tonne jusqu'en 2022
mais ces chiffres 200 $ 200 dollars la
tonne cécilia rien d'autre qu'un prix
sur le pétrole -quelque un prix sur la
pollution
nous on a choisi de faire bien d'autres
choses aussi de protéger la nature
encore plus d'investir dans de finir
avec les centrales du charbon de bannir
le plastique à usage unique de planter
deux milliards d'arbres aussi que ça
prend énormément d'efforts pour le faire
mais on va le faire
parce qu on a fait plus déjà que tout
autre gouvernement dans l'histoire du
pays pour protéger l'environnement et
contrer les changements climatiques le
débat est ouvert
ouais merci mais le problème c'est
lequel ce n'est pas suffisant de parler
seulement de prix sur crown
on doit mettre sur pied les cibles qui
sont alignés avec l'avis des
scientifiques et maintenant ce n'est pas
le troc pour son audition le niveau de
2005 par 2030 les cibles de mesures tout
de même cible que monsieur harper est
absolument insuffisant on doit mettre
sur pied à plaindre vers vous
élimination des énergies fossiles par
2050 et pas 2030 60 % de réduction de
gaz à effet de serre etc vous aimons
possible notre place s'appelle mission
possible parce qu'il reste possible ce
n'est pas facile mais il est possible
mais ce n'est pas avec seulement des
taxes carbone genou demanderais d'être
plus précis oui il faut arriver à ce que
le seul pétrole qu'on utilise soit et du
pétrole qui ne sera pas utilisée à
combustion assassin à autre chose un peu
il faut mettre une date là dessus une
fois qu'on avait une date il faut
calculer c'est combien de réduction par
année dans l'extraction par le transport
dans l'exportation et dans la
consommation
il faut pas dire on va en parler en 2030
on en 2025 il faut dire on commence ce
donc c'est moins 3% l'année prochaine
-3% l'autre et ça exclut évidemment
d'aller chercher le 173 milliards de
baril de pétrole qui reste en alberta
c'est totalement exclu sur la taxe à
proprement parler nous on a proposé ce
qu'on appelait la péréquation verte
moyenne des émissions à travers le
canada les provinces qui sont tous tu
paies cette taxe et celles qui sont en
dessous reçoivent cette taxe c'est
strictement administratif aucun
changement constitutionnel n'est requis
pommettes sont en oeuvre et ça pourrait
faire une mesure très incitative et tout
le monde sait cette initiative monsieur
blanchet souligne un des grands défis
que vous avez en tant que chef du bloc
québécois c'est que pour imposer un plan
pancanadien ça prend un gouvernement
prêt à le faire à tenir tête contre
jason kenny contre les pétrolières
contre d'oxford contre ces politiciens
conservateurs qui ne veulent rien faire
pour l'environnement et on est quatre
ici on dépend de nouveaux dépôts pour
protéger l'environnement qui veulent
lutter qui ont fait beaucoup au courant
des quatre dernières années
on en a fait énormément mais on
reconnaît qu'il faut continuer c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas arrêter faut que
les québécois que les francophones que
les canadiens fassent partie d'un
gouvernement qui veut lutter contre les
changements climatiques
la vraie réalité c'est que la situation
maintenant c'est un situations d'urgence
climatique
je parle de fond de mon coeur parce que
le temps presse et maintenant tous les
autres chefs ici dans la scène avec moi
il n'y a personne avec un plan qui
marche pour éviter le pire clattenburg a
raison notre maison est enfin comment
osez-vous mais surtout sur le pipeline
prix tout doux sur le pipeline monsieur
shearer été clair dans la campagne il
pourrait imposer un pipeline vers l'est
donc qui traverserait entre autres le
québec
vous avez pas été clair il n'y a pas de
projet il peut avoir demain matin un
projet sur la table
pourriez vous oui ou non imposer un
pipeline ça fait partie d'un processus
qui doit avoir l'approbation des
communautés l'approbation des peuples
autochtones de travailler avec avec les
avec les scientifiques pour assurer
l'impact et on va procéder comme on a
procédé avec l'oléoduc trans maintain
pour essayer de chercher l'approbation
et pour le faire de façon rigoureuse
les gens savent faut pas avoir plus de
pétrole par rail ça déjà c'est très
dangereux et plus polluants faut pouvoir
mettre les profits de ce qu'on a besoin
maintenant parce que la transition
ça ne fait pas tout de suite vers
l'énergie verte vers la lutte contre les
changements climatiques et chaque dollar
de profits ira justement pour déminer
vous propose et dieu que les éléphants
public pour l eau les autochtones
situations d'urgence publique en urgence
climatique
on doit arrêter tous les oléoducs on
doit arrêter le gaz de schiste partout
au canada
si on a un seul chance d'éviter le pire
c'est dont l'avis des scientifiques ce
n'est pas une question de les cibles en
politique c'est un question de l'arrêt a
été blanchi
deux choses le québec veulent pas est ce
que vous allez dire au québec non il n'y
aura pas de léo duc au québec et la
deuxième chose si on fait des
propositions voulu trouver bonne
votre seul argument c'est un beauf et
pas les mettre en place mais sont fait
des propositions allez vous voter pour
au parlement c'est sans parlement la
bonne idée peut venir de n'importe qui
réponse monsieur trudeau avant de passer
à l'autre trio on a créé un système avec
ses 69 qui permet d'avoir de
l'approbation ce pour les bons projets
et les mauvais projets n'avancent combat
auquel un bon projet pour un courrier
pour l'imposer écoutez c'est mieux que
2-2 du plus de pétrole sur rails
monsieur deuxième confrontation à trois
messieurs signe bernier et chez on va
poursuivre sur cette histoire de
pipelines qui a fait beaucoup jaser dans
cette campagne électorale le
gouvernement legault répète qu'il n'ya
pas donc au québec d'acceptabilité
sociale monsieur bernier chez vous est
favorable
un pipeline si vous étiez de sylla
consciente la musique canadienne qui
nous donne le droit
ne craignez-vous pas un ressac un
sentiment anti canada au québec où un
sentiment anti québec dans l'ouest si
vous aller de l'avant nous imposer un
pipeline mais ce chiffre mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle que j'ai proposé
mon corridor énergétique parce que je
sais que les québécois et québécoises
préfère l'énergie de chez nous à ce
moment beaucoup d'argent des
consommateurs québécois vont aux états
unis vont acheter le pétrole des états
unis ya aucune bon sens je veux créer
les conditions où le québec pour
partager son idole et les ressources
naturelles groupe pourrait être renvoyé
de l'ouest canada dans les marchés
laisse ses meilleurs pour les québécois
et québécoises et pour tous les
canadiens
le corridor énergétique que monsieur
scheer propos ça va prendre des années
avant de construire et l'urgence d'avoir
un oléoduc et vous avez raison de dire
en ce concerne la conscience et la paix
confessionnelle et l'unité du pays
c'est pour ça les gens en alberta
demande effectivement qu'on puisse
exporter leur pétrole dans l'eau un
autre marché que le marché américain et
avec monsieur scheer je prends certain
qu'il va utiliser la constitution pour
s'assurer qu'on soit capable de
construire des pipelines
mais le plus important c'est que
monsieur scheer et monsieur trudeau
la même position à ce qui concerne les
changements climatiques la seule
différence est que monsieur si on voit
imposer des tarifs élevés aux grosses
d'émetteurs et je pense que je vais
ambitions ici à l'énergie fossile nous
ont dit on veut laisser ça aux provinces
le québec fait bien pour les changements
climatiques
on devrait laisser sa province et
s'occuper des vrais des vraies actions
pour l'environnement je pense que je
peux résumer la situation aussi pour les
spectateurs
ici ces messieurs publie ici mais ces
messieurs pipeline encore et monsieur
trudeau je pense aussi ces messieurs
pipeline
moi je suis de jacques médecin si je ne
vais jamais imposé un pipeline sur le
québec c'est que là vous avez interpellé
monsieur je me suis fait l'option
actuelle de monsieur très dur c'était de
donner les grands exemption de cordes et
sans taxe carbone pour les grands
pollueurs les grandes compagnies qui a
négocié une entente spéciale mais les
contribuables les travailleurs canadiens
doit p
s'empressant d'attac sacrement j'ai
aucune taxe d'eau dans la maison des
tarifs une vie sentimentale est si
souvent sion en plus activement sinon tu
ne va rien y poser tout ne va même pas
gagné en force au québec maintenant les
gens que les canadiens taper la taxe et
vous allez voir l'occasion dans les
technologies nous avons prendre la lutte
contre les changements climatiques dans
un contexte global ça c'est la chose qui
manque dans tous les plats très bien
répondu pour l'avenir jean votre cadeau
aux riches dans un contexte global c'est
ça monsieur qui veut prendre l'argent
des canadiens pour faire des sorties
contre l' échange d'actions mais ce
chiffre compte lutter contre les
changements climatiques dans d'autres
pays et donner encore des millions ou
des milliards de dollars pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques
ailleurs le plus important c'est de
s'assurer que l'environnement ici au
canada soient protégés et aujourd'hui on
a encore 215 milliards de litres d'eaux
usées qui sont déversés dans nos
rivières dans nos lacs dans nos océans
c'est une augmentation de 10% par
rapport à 2013 il faut corriger ça et
investir ici pour les canadiens monsieur
c'est non pas les commerçants
singh on a eu cinq cent mille enfants
des de la jeunesse dans les roues à
marianne les jeunes disent il faut agir
dès maintenant
on a mis surtout trudeau qui est oui un
grand parleur un grand pas l'heure mais
en fait c'est un petit father et ne
marche pas pour les gens et me travaille
pour le prodige en ce qu'il faut dès
maintenant c'est de donner aux jeunes
d'espoir on peut dire que oui on peut
aller de l'avant ont annulé les
subventions pétrolières très investi
dans l'énergie propre
on peut massivement investir dans le
transport en commun on peut agir dès
maintenant et il faut agir dès
maintenant
il monsieur bernier et monsieur
chirurgie une question pour vous pour
relancer le débat
vous voulez annulé la taxe carbone est
ce que ce n'est pas donner un permis de
polluer
avis aux entreprises je bénirai
absolument pas écouté actuellement il
n'y a pas de taxe sur le carbone pour le
québec
effectivement donc on veut laisser les
provinces l'environnement c'est une
compétence partagée avec le fédéral et
les provinces et nous notre plan ce
qu'ont dit les provinces peuvent
s'occuper des changements climatiques et
nous au fédéral on va continuer à
dépolluer nouveau la knu rivières c'est
important c'est incroyable qu'en 2019 on
a encore des hawks sont usées qui sont
jetés déjà ville de montréal fait ça et
là c'est maintenant la ville de
vancouver et on veut avoir un
environnement plus propre mais il serait
bien vous cherchiez mais sous celle sur
la taxe carbone sur la taxe carbone est
c'est clair qu'avec messi trouve avec le
plan actuel et le gouvernement libéral
il a donné une grande exemption ou les
grands pollueurs alors quand le dit
qu'il avait il pris cela crée bon c'est
pas pour les grands pour l'heure c'est
seulement pour les gens ordinaires
l'église les travailleurs et ça c'est le
problème avec ce rapprochement la presse
je vais mettre une concentration sur les
technologies par les taxes le problème
avec messieurs c'est votre plane était
écrit par et pour le secteur
ce n'est pas acceptable merci messieurs
savait faire ce deuxième trio je vous
félicite rapidement pour votre
discipline
jusqu'ici ça va bien françois cardinal
éditorialiste à la presse bonsoir
françois soir patrice vos questions au
chef madame et je commence avec vous
vous voulez réduire les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de manière drastique au
pays pour éviter le pays où l'avait dit
tout à l'heure je vous pose des
questions directement
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
décroissance de l'économie canadienne
même si certains soutiennent que ça
pourrait provoquer beaucoup de pertes
d'emplois merci monsieur canon c'est une
question extrêmement pertinents non mais
pas en faveur de des cross de croissance
des économies 15 mai pour la
transformation économique canadien parce
que nous avons besoin c'est vrai que
nous avons besoin comme mais je suis
heureux dit pour la structure nationale
accorde aux mais pas pour les oléoducs
seulement pour l'électricité des grands
venise et avec un grand croissance de
notre capacité dans les renouvelables
énergies renouvelables devant de soleil
manon avec le prix de soleil qui a le
trombe et énormément
nous avons les opportunités économiques
sans pétrole
merci madame mes prochaines questions
pour monsieur blanchet une coupe
question pour vous aussi vous dit très
fier de votre plateforme
environnementale vous avez parlé de la
péréquation verte tout honneur comment
vous expliquez votre haie puis au
troisième lien entre québec et lévis
d'abord je n'ai pas appuyer le troisième
y est j'ai dit que j'étais pas contre et
j'ai dit que le dépôt pour une raison
fort simple
d'abord le ministre de l'environnement
vient de commander un bac
moi j'ai déjà été mêlé de
l'environnement au québec je respecte le
battre alors si on demande à une
institution dont nous on veut proposer
par loi qu'elle ait préséance sur les
évaluations environnementales du fédéral
sûrement des institutions de faire une
analyse environnementale de projets on
va attendre l'analyse environnementale
du projet et ultime ans le troisième les
exclusivement du gouvernement du québec
et non pas du fédéral cp ingérences
répétées fini par être très irritantes
je suis convaincu que québec pourra
prendre les bonnes décisions après le
bac
merci monsieur blanchet monsieur chien
vous êtes pour la lutte contre les
changements climatiques
mais vous obtenez toujours est précisé
que cette à condition qu'elle se fasse à
l'échelle mondiale est ce une autre
façon commandes de demander aux autres
pays de faire
des efforts pendant que le canadien lui
continue de polluer comme si de rien
n'était pas du tout avec mon plan nous
avons une approche équilibrée
nous avons là beaucoup des mesures pour
réduire nos émissions
par exemple avec l'investissement dans
la technologie un crédit d'impôt pour
les compressions qui a qui adoptent de
nouveaux façon de les méthodes de
production mais on doit reconnaître le
fait que le canada ait mis seulement 1,6
pour cent des émissions et quand et si
on chasse tous les investissements tous
les emplois rendre la vie plus chère
pour tous les chrétiens et on voit
l'économie de la chine de ligne
remplacer tous nos émissions on perd
enfin on accomplit rien et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons une
approche mondiale
merci monsieur scheer monsieur signe
l'an dernier en début d'année vous
n'étiez pas contre l'expansion du
pipeline trans fenton puis vous avez
finalement décidé de vous y opposer au
fil de l'année
comment comprendre vos contorsions et
volte face sur les projets de transport
de gaz et pétrole
donc pour moi c'est clair la future de
notre pays de futur de notre planète
c'est un futur où on n'utilise pas
hockin énergies fossiles ça c'est
l'avenir
est ce que je veux faire pour les
enfants qui s'inquiètent de l'avenir
pour les familles qui ont font face des
inondations pour les gens qui me disent
qu'ils ont peur des feux de forêt je
veux dire je vais mettre tous mes
efforts pour s'attaquer à la crise
climatique il faut le faire on peut le
faire et pour moi c'est un engagement
forte
merci monsieur singh monsieur trudeau
vous avez premier en 2015 de mettre fin
aux subventions à l'industrie pétrolière
et pourtant vous avez non seulement
acheter un pipeline pendant votre mandat
on en a parlé tout à l'heure mais vous
avez aussi à faire un programme d'un de
plus de 1 milliard de dollars à
l'industrie pétrolière comment
aujourd'hui peut-on croire vos promesses
environnementales
on est encore en train d'atteindre nos
cibles d'éliminer les subventions à
l'industrie pétrolière jusqu'en 2025
ça prend une progression aussi que la
transition ne peut pas se faire du jour
au lendemain
c'est pour ça qu'on est en train
d'investir de la bonne façon dans
l'énergie verte dans l'énergie
renouvelable et tous les profits des
centaines de millions de dollars de cet
oléoduc vont aller vers cette transition
vers la lutte contre les changements
climatiques
on a un vrai plan parce qu'on le livret
pendant quatre ans il faut continuer
faut avoir un gouvernement fort plein de
québécois plein de francophones qui vont
pouvoir continuer de tenir tête contre
des conservateurs qui veulent rien faire
merci monsieur trudeau dernière question
pour vous monsieur bernier vous êtes le
seul chef à refuser le consensus
scientifique sur l'urgence climatique en
citant toujours la même poignée de
détracteurs plutôt controversé monsieur
bernier pourquoi renier vous la science
premièrement je ne renie pas la science
et deuxièmement faut bien dire que 500
scientifiques à travers le monde qui ont
écrit au secrétaire général de l'onu
pour dire qu'il n'y avait pas d'urgence
climatique donc je ne suis pas le seul
il faut bâtir des politiques publiques
non pas sur des sentiments et une
urgence qui une urgence qui n'existe pas
mais sur l'effet sur la raison et ce
qu'on demande qui encore plus d'études
sur l'impact du soleil par rapport aux
changements climatiques
les études qu'ils ont eue actuellement
était seulement sur l'impact co2 et si
vous voulez vraiment atteindre les
cibles
il est la bête à la raison elle a des
cibles qui vont qui vont faire en sorte
qu'on va atteindre les cibles de paris
mais elle va détruire l'économie comme
vous l'avez dit plus tôt c'est la seule
chef qui est crédible tout en détruisant
l'économie merci monsieur bernier merci
merci en soit merci beaucoup
alors on est déjà
à notre deuxième thème économie et
finances publiques et nous avons dans la
salle une citoyenne marie saint jean qui
veut poser une question du chef madame
saint-jean bonsoir à vous pensez merci à
vous tous merci d'être là votre question
il vous écoute en voici lorsqu'on est
âgé et à la retraite
il en coûte beaucoup plus cher de vivre
ce cas deux savez tout ça et on peut pas
bénéficier entre autres du partage des
revenus qu'on est seul pour absorber
toutes les dépenses alors prévoyez vous
augmentez les pensions des retraités ou
encore majoré la déduction en raison de
l'âge en d'autres mots quelles mesures
fiscales
prévoyez vous pour aider les personnes
âgées vivant seules
très bonne question très clair merci
beaucoup madame st jacques monsieur
blanchet vous répondez en premier
bonjour madame st jean le prémisse que
vous mettez en place et lit remarquable
d'abord parce que il ya une forte qu à
qu'on appelle les baby boomer qui vont
arriver à la retraite une retraite qu'il
mérite heureuse et qu'il mérite
passablement prospère parce qu'ils ont
construit la société dans laquelle on
vit
nous on propose l'augmentation de 110
dollars par mois de la pension des yes
emportant plusieurs crédits d'impôt sur
les activités physiques un congé de ou
une prolongation du versement pour le
conjoint lors du décès du conjoint la
protection des fonds de pension comme
créancier prioritaire lors d'une
faillite ou de la cessation des
activités d'une entreprise un ensemble
de mesures que je vous invite à
consulter dans le détail on répondra à
vos questions
parce que on pense que c'est important
de dire merci monsieur blanchet monsieur
c'est clair que là coût de la vie est un
autre enjeu très important dans ses
crampons
c'est le thème central de notre
plateforme on va rendre la vie plus
abordable pour tous les canadiens que
indienne pour les québécois et
québécoises spécifiquement pour les
personnages et les gens là qui à prendre
qui a pris leur retraite on va augmenter
le crédit en raison d'âge à 1000 $ aussi
à beaucoup de nos crédits d'impôt va
appliquer à
allez allez personnes âgées comme le
crédit d'impôt pour le transport en
commun et aussi on va éliminer la tps
pour les factures d'eau messier et pour
les personnes avec une crème fixer les
revenus fixes et ça c'est important
merci monsieur cher monsieur trudeau
merci même et saint jean pour être
question la première une des premières
choses que nous avons fait c'est
d'augmenter le supplément de revenu
garanti pour nos aînés les plus
vulnérables souvent des femmes seules
mais on sait qu'il ya encore plus à
faire c'est pour ça qu'on a promis de
bonifier la sécurité de la vieillesse
à partir de l'âge de 75 ans de 10%
ici à une personne âgée qui perd son
conjoint
c'est un moment extrêmement difficile et
c'est pour ça qu'on va augmenter les
pensions de survivants des régime des
rentes de jusqu'à 75% de ce qu'ils
recevaient avant parce qu'on sait que
d'appuyer nos aînés c'est essentiel dans
une société riche généreuse comme
l'anneau merci monsieur trudeau madame
mais votre réponse merci madame ce sens
jacques je veux ajouter parce que j'ai
oublié un commencement que je
reconnaître que nous sommes ici
autochtone ans et des coquins jeudi mais
gouache
maintenant je veux dire que oui le parti
vert sont vraiment engagés pour
augmenter le niveau de pension pour
aider les âges et moi même j'ai 65 ans
alors je suis absolument dont le même
position mais je ne suis pas en parler
de retraite immédiatement alors je veux
faire aussi un métier en stratégie pour
les années et aussi mes deux pieds dans
la cabine cédera ministre avec le but de
protéger
merci madame et monsieur bernier
mais on vient de s'apercevoir que tous
les autres chefs ici pourra même vous
promettre que vous ce que vous voulez
entendre et donc faire en sorte qu'on va
augmenter les pensions pour les aînés
moi je vous dis la vérité c'est la
vérité c'est que le pays est endetté
on n'a pas les moyens et la seule
promesse que je vous fais c'est
d'équilibrer le budget en deux ans et
après ça seulement après ça on va
regarder pour baisser les taxes et les
impôts mais les gens ici il n'y a pas de
limite
y a pas de déficit et c'est comme si
rien n'était et pour les programmes
sociaux pour les programmes canadiens
c'est important d'équilibrer notre
budget tout de suite parce que si jamais
une récession dans quelques années on
n'aura plus de marge de manoeuvre
donc je ne sais pas d'acheter votre vote
avec votre argent je vous dire ses
vérités
merci monsieur même je saigne terminée
oui mais si madame la question avez vous
avez soulevé un enjeu qui touche
beaucoup de monde
merci pour prendre le temps pour
expliquer ça je pense que c'est
tellement seulement à ridicule que les
personnes âgées font face des grands
défis comme ça les gens qui ont ces
sacrifices et beaucoup ils ont le droit
d'avoir la retraite avec la dignité ce
qu'on va faire c'est de mettre en oeuvre
des programmes pour vous aider oui il
faut augmenter les pressions aussi il
veut il faut augmenter les services
comme la science médicament universel
qui va sauver son teint de la doller le
soin dentaire nationale qui va aussi
réduire les coûts et sauver d'argent ou
si on veut mettre en oeuvre une limite
sur les fesses c'est lui là savent aussi
c'est l'argent merci à vous merci
monsieur séguin est ce que vous êtes un
peu plus éclairées quant à votre vote je
vous demande pas pour qui bien sûr mais
tous les programmes sont intéressants
alors on verra dans quatre à merci merci
beaucoup pour votre passion merci alors
premier trio économique avec monsieur
singh madame mais et monsieur blanchet
aucun de vous trois ne proposer des
baisses d'impôts au contraire vous
promettez vous venez d'en parler
monsieur rapidement de nouvelles taxes
de nouveaux programmes coûteux
vous ne pensez pas que la classe moyenne
a besoin d'un répit j'commence avec vous
monsieur c je pense que les classes
moyennes a besoin des aides
donc on va jamais augmenter les taxes
sur les classes moyennes où les
travailleurs et travailleuses mais là
problème c'est les plus riches et nappez
parle juste par les plus riches ont
beaucoup d'argent et ne le partage pas
donc ce qu'on va faire
pas des belles paroles et pas des
actions comme sur le dos mais on va
mettre en place un taxe sur les
ultra-riches ça va donner une
augmentation de revenus de 77 milliards
de dollars donc on peut trouver l'argent
si on veut investir dans les gens
on est vu les autres gouvernement qui
investit dans les grands combats ni avec
des milliards de dollars moi je vais
investir dans les gens parce que je ne
travaille pas plus riches
je travaille pour vous pour les plus
riches et notre programme et nous avons
le seul programme dans ces élections
chifflet nous avons un frère forme
chiffrée nous avons les preuves de
chercher les revenus comme ton quand
monsieur singh aussi dit que sur les
taxes sur les plus riches mais aussi
pour klaxonner leweb gillon comme
facebook et neflix et chercher les fonds
parce que on doit mettre sur pied plus
pour les citoyens du canada éliminé les
frais de scolarité investissez dont
l'éducation postsecondaire et aussi nous
sommes absolument engager pour un
programme de l'assurance médicaments
mais en même temps pour la livraison
postale à domicile tous les choses sont
possibles son possible pour aider les ag
mais on doit choisir les priorités et
trouver leur est venue pour équilibrer
le budget en cinq ans jette sur la glace
à vous de jouer ce bétail inexactes fois
à part monsieur scheer et monsieur 5
tout le monde a déposé je crois des
plateformes financières déposer des
cadres financiers qu'ils respectent les
règles en notant que je suis concernée
je suis d'accord sur le principe qu'il
faut aller chercher davantage de revenus
il faut pas que ces revenus là viennent
toujours des mêmes poches
or il est exact qu'il y a des paradis
fiscaux de l'évasion fiscale qui
favorise toujours les mêmes
il est exact qu'on peut faire en sorte
avec les géants du web avec une
redevance de 3% dont je pense par contre
qui doit être réservé l'argent c'est
beaucoup d'argent loin dans les
centaines de millions $ réservé au
secteur culturel et des médias qui en
ont bien besoin
donc je pense qu'il faut travailler dans
ce sens là mais je pense qu'on peut
regarder les revenus de la péréquation
verte qui vont baisser les dépenses
fédérales parce que ça va venir des
provinces plus riches et je pense qu'on
peut regarder les 400 millions de
dollars d'une déclaration d'impôt unique
qui sera sauvé aux contribuables aux
entreprises et à l'état demande unanime
de l'assemblée nationale du québec
demandent que le bloc portera bien sûr
on aura l'aide éventuellement des
conservateurs qui disaient d'accord avec
ça et monsieur 5e le disque était
d'accord s'il n'y avait pas de pertes
d'emplois
c'est si je pense que là dessus on est
tous d'accord il n'y aurait pas de
pertes d'emplois fixes a donc voici 400
millions de dollars
oui je vais aussi ajouté un autre point
c'est une question de revenus mais c'est
aussi une question de choix donc dans le
derrière nez à nez ce que monsieur
trudeau a fait dépenser beaucoup de
dollars 14 milliards de dollars pour les
plus riches entreprises faut qu'ils
puissent acheter des avions d'éléments
dans l'économie de l'automne juste que
ça l a dit à 4,5 milliards de dollars
pour acheter un pipeline et pour les
prêts pour les grands compagnie des
grandes entreprises il a dit il va
annuler 6 milliards de dettes pour les
complications de grandes compagnies en
général pour moi ça c'est 20 5 millions
de dollars qu'elle a donnée est plus
riches au lieu des données très bien aux
messes commencé pour eux sur madame est
ce qu'on a beaucoup reçu comme courriel
comme questions du public
c'est l'inquiétude vis-à-vis cette dette
qui grandit et du difficile alors on a
un mot là vous trois
est ce que ça vous inquiète tout ça vous
inquiète paul difficiles à tuer le
déficit inquiète parce que le
gouvernement libéral a fait pour donner
des milliards de dollars aux plus riches
si on prend des actions pour investir
dans les gens dont je suis une âme et
avec notre plateforme chiffrait le
bourget sera écrit vrai en cinq ans un
événement comme en récession mais en
même temps je vais ajouter que les
subventions der l'énergie fossile ont
augmenté depuis les dernières qu'attend
aller chercher l'argent dans les poches
des riches est une chose faire en sorte
que ça et au bon endroit est une chose
baisser le déficit en ethno simon peut
pas du jour au lendemain
dire on va couper un déficit de 19
milliards parce que l'impact sur
l'économie de l'ensemble du pays et du
québec serait catastrophique
notre plateforme nous sa baisse à peu
près de la moitié difficile je trouve
pas ça merveilleux mais on peut pas
aller plus vite que ça faut vraiment
aller chercher les revenus
supplémentaires il faut vraiment faire
en sorte que ça allait chercher de
l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables
les entreprises les géants du web
couper les subventions toutes les formes
des reventes transmanche ne pas investir
dans la réfection prince membres sont
des moyens d'aller chercher beaucoup
d'argent merci à vous trois deuxième
trio sur l'économie monsieur bernier
monsieur trudeau et monsieur chien
monsieur trudeau vous n'avez pas de plat
aucun plan de retour avec les
budgétaires monsieur bernier vous voulez
coupé allègrement vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
monsieur chier on n'a toujours pas vos
chiffres vous donnez votre cadre
financier quand on peut savoir où vous
allez coupé alors premièrement j'ai fait
une haie engagement très clair on va
équilibrer le budget en cinq ans et
toutes nos annonces étaient tout chiffré
par le directeur parlementaire du budget
ça c'est au contraire 2006 trader qui a
présenté une plateforme écrit sur napkin
au coin de table
parce que aucune peu près près de 5 en
présence de ses engagements le chiffre
pourquoi on a préféré un verdict année
on a représenté 1 400 écrit complet
chiffré à prouver à des parlementaires
du budget mais la réalité c'est qu'on
avait tellement d'ambition pour les
investissements les baisses d'impôts
pour la classe moyenne mais jean les
chiens on n'a pas baissé les impôts des
plus riches
vous promettez une baisse d'impôt de 50
mille dollars estime millionnaire si
vous avez une baisse d'impôts et jack
celle qui est plus les familles qui font
de ce jeu juste une année qui que
finissez votre idée après monsieur
berniche d'associer un mensonge vous
avez menti quand les premières à sortir
l'histoire vous avez menti quand vous
avez dit que je l'aimais française y
cherchiez vous montez la classe moyenne
par an dit qu'il est on les a augmentées
pour les plus riches
vous avez j'ai très bien commencé mais
ce sera un à la fois jusqu'à la fin
messieurs de chez verdier mais je
regarde ici
les chefs des partis si vous disent tout
qu'ils vont équilibrer le budget en cinq
ans et vous demande un mandat de quatre
ans
donc personne va équilibrer le budget
monsieur scheer va additionner 70
milliards de dollars sur la dette
monsieur trudeau va faire la même chose
c'est irresponsable
les finances publiques on ne peut plus
additionner la carte de crédit
nationales et les plaines et pour faire
en sorte la seule promesse que fait vous
l'avez dit c'est des coupures
on peut couper les subventions aux
entreprises monsieur jiva continuer à
donner des subventions aux entreprises
son trou d'eau ici et si on veut
relancer l'économie pour remettre de
l'argent n'arrête pas les entrepreneurs
les entrepreneurs beaucerons en beauce
et entrepreneurs de partout mais et nous
on va le faire parce qu'on va trouver
l'argent
merci conservateurs on l'entend du bien
souvent on l'a vu pendant dix ans sous
monsieur rhdp où vous étiez tous les
deux à faisait partie de ce parti on a
vu des coupures on a vu des baisses
d'impôts pour les mieux nantis on a vu
des sous-investissements dans
l'infrastructure dans les personnes
âgées dans nos jeunes et sa pole livrer
une croissance économique depuis quatre
ans des investissements dans la classe
moyenne 11 millions d'emplois créés on a
eu les plus bas taux de chômage de libye
et on a 1000 à 5000 personnes jugées à
trop des mensonges dans cette discours
que j'attends de répandre les légions de
leurs revenus faibles à bonifier le plus
de notre plan économique et c'est
l'excusé pour les grands déficits de
judith société pour dépenser l'argent
dans les futures et là directeur parle
de bouchehr alimentaire a dit qu' à
aucun plan
alors quand les pierres de l'est du
monde râle les grands déficits et aucune
projet de désir de désinvolture et la
cour la cour de ses déficits augmentent
et elles demandent le plus plus en plus
d'argent des contribuables doit à
l'épopée l'intérêt d'un investissement
en infrastructure les gens peuvent aller
voir dans leurs villes dans leur
communauté les investissements 50 chute
de la veille
logement social les investissements
qu'on a choisi de faire parce que les
conservateurs sous monsieur harper nous
ont sous investi et nous on a fait le
choix des désirs de façon raisonnable
dans notre avenir
vous avez créé un déficit et vous avez
créé actuellement l'intérêt sur la dette
seulement ces 26 milliards de dollars
par année
y a plus de marge de manoeuvre c'est
irresponsable et actuellement plusieurs
économistes disent monsieur trudeau
qu'on risque de s'en aller vers une
récession dans quelques années ici c'est
le cas ça va être désastreux pour les
programmes sociaux il faut avoir une
politique responsable et ce n'est pas en
dépensant l'argent du gouvernement que
vous créiez la richesse si vous voulez
que je l'avais su franchir les
investissements dans les gens dans les
travailleurs dans les familles sakri la
résilience dans les familles dans les
communautés c'est pas de garder un
groupe ou d'argent pour quand on en a
besoin a glissé que de lui donner les
investissements aux gens pour te faire
de la résilience c'est ça qui va nous de
créer des opportunités saisies dans les
temps difficiles à comprendre et
coupures nouveau sur le dos justin
trudeau a augmenté le chiffre monsieur
chirurgie commencez à vous poser une
question intérieure augmente et la lutte
fiscale tous les cas il a augmenté les
impôts pour 80 % des familles de la
classe nous avons proposé un plan d
équilibrer le budget tension ne pourront
même je vous sens du tour d'oman où s'en
vont j'ai pas le droit d'apporter une
malfaçon mais je les monte bien sourit
de cinq ans nous avons en gagna faut
qu'une lettre parce que vous remercie
merci merci merci merci fin de bloc
c'est normal ça s'échauffe sénégal
pensez aux gens la maison pensez aux
gens à la maison à qui vous voulez
envoyer vos messages
en même temps ça passe plus hélène
buzzetti du devoir dont soir patrice
question cherche sur autre chose ce
thème d'icônes messieurs si on commence
avec vous d'abord très rapidement parce
que plusieurs citoyens nous ont écrit à
ce sujet allez-vous changer l'âge de la
retraite qui est à 60,50 non bon alors
on n'a toujours pas votre cadre
financier mais vous voulez rééquilibrer
le budget en cinq ans le précédent
gouvernement conservateur a découpé dans
la culture et la recherche scientifique
vous est ce que vous allez faire la même
chose pour éliminer le déficit
alors nous avons déjà annoncé à les
endroits où on va trouver les épargnants
pour les canadiens qui on va protéger la
clôture à va protéger les
investissements dans les technologies et
de la région on va éliminer 1 5 milliard
de dollars pour les subventions
coopératif et on va couper l'aide
étrangère par 20 5% on va rester hors va
garder cet argent ici chez nous
lorsqu'on peut rendre la vie plus
abordable on va baisser les impôts on va
réintroduire les crédits d'impôt pour
les activités ce n'est pas de coupure
anciens c'est ça et le racisme haïr est
d'accord la prochaine question mais pour
monsieur bernier monsieur bernier vous
avez promis d'abolir la gestion de
l'offre en agriculture
alors qu'on parle de plus en plus
d'acheter et de manger local qu'est ce
que vous dites oh conso consommateurs
qui craignent de voir leurs tablettes
d'épicerie inondé par du lait et du
poulet produit aux états unis par
exemple
premièrement ils vont avoir la liberté
de choix et les produits qui vont devoir
venir au canada vont devoir respecter
les normes sanitaires canadiennes c'est
très important
mais le plus important c'est que chaque
famille indienne va sauver 400 dollars
et sonné par année si on est sérieux on
veut faut abolir ce système look et un
système socialiste un cartel mais le
plus important monsieur scheer viennent
dire tout à l'heure qui va essayer
d'équilibrer le budget en faisant des
coupures c'est facile d'équilibrer le
budget il s'agit de couper l'aide
internationale on peut économiser cinq
milliards là il faut rapatrier cet
argent alors ici au canada prédit les
candidats bas il une des choses qu'on
peut faire pour aider les plus démunis
c'est effectivement abolir ce cartel ce
cartel de la gestion de l'offre les
familles canadiennes vont économiser
merci
madame mais votre cadre financier ont
été démolies par ce que vous proposez
d'ajouter soixante dix milliards de
dépenses dès la première année
comment allez vous convaincre les
électeurs que vous êtes crédibles en
matière de finances publiques parce que
notre plateforme chiffre est étudié par
l'institut fiscale pour la démarque
aussi avec notre relation directeur du
bureau parlementaire de bouger mais sur
kevin page et il est donné le budget un
bonne note
ouais ouais c'est la passe et il adorait
ça oui mais c'est vrai que nous sommes
de se lever avec un tout programme
grands-parents thief r espect le rail
arrêté c'est que on doit faire plus nous
sommes un pays riche
on doit augmenter notre système pour
justice sociale on doit faire plus pour
le soin des enfants pour les garderies
pour les personnes âgées et c'est
vraiment possible c'est tout con à merci
monsieur trudeau en 2015 vous proposiez
des déficits pour investir dans les
infrastructures et les électeurs vous
ont suivi en 2019 vous proposer encore
de vivre à crédit d'alourdir la dette de
100 milliards mais maintenant c'est pour
des dépenses courantes
si jamais il ya une récession quelle
marge de manoeuvre aux rives
nous on croit que l'important c'est de
pouvoir aider nos jeunes à trouver de
bons emplois à voir l'éducation
nécessaire à aider les familles à
pouvoir offrir les opportunités à leurs
enfants pour qu'ils puissent grandir en
sécurité avec toutes les opportunités
qui pourraient avoir ces investissements
ç'a fonctionné pendant quatre ans on a
vu neuf cent mille personnes sorties de
l'ancien récession monsieur trudeau c
est ce que vous aurez les marges de
manoeuvres où on va être obligé d'avoir
des déficits deux fois trois fois plus
élevé oui on va voir la marge de
manoeuvre parce que notre plan a été
coté triple à par les les
agences de crédit à l'international de
juste l'allemagne et le canada qui a qui
ont un crédit unanime de premier plan
parce que notre plan est responsable et
raisonnable sur le cadre fiscal
merci monsieur singh comme monsieur
chien vous avez ça en partage vous avez
toujours pas votre cadre financier mais
on sait que vous promettez des
programmes très coûteux par exemple
l'assurance médicaments l'assurance
dentaire vous dit toujours que vous
allez faire payer les riches
mais les experts nous disent que on
surestime toujours l'argent qu'on peut
aller chercher de ce côté là c'est connu
les red lions des bons fiscaliste alors
comment allez-vous dissiper l'impression
que votre plan relève un peu de la
pensée magique
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est un on pense
que c'est important de le faire
donc oui c'est difficile de faire les
bonnes choses mais on a le courage de le
faire quand même
ah mais aussi on a choisi des chiffres
tellement spécifique parce qu'on sait
avec la taxe l'autriche
on a dit pour les gens qui ont plus de
20 millions $ on va mettre un texte 1%
parce que on a évalué qu avec un pur
sang c'est plus difficile pour échapper
l'argent que dans le pays
donc on n'était pas respecté ça mais en
général on sait que si on augmente les
financements pour leurs revenus de
s'assurer qu'on a c'est révolu on peut
le faire avec les financements des
employés qui cherchent l'argent dans
notre gourmand en prédateur merci
monsieur blanchet enfin vous êtes
content les pipelines
mais vous ne donne on sait toujours pas
le gazoduc gnl québec qui se rendra
jusqu'à saint denis dit nous est ce que
vous vous opposez aux hydrocarbures
seulement quand c'est l'alberta qui
empochent les profits a fait en toute
cohérence et j'ai déjà répondu un peu
sont un peu plus tôt garin bureau
d'audiences publiques en environnement
bape sur le projet de gnl
j'étais assez clair sur le fait que je
pense que les hydrocarbures puis les
énergies fossiles sont les énergies du
passé n'a pas d'avenir là dedans c'est
pas par là qu'il faut aller c'est pas
ces projets là qu'il faut réaliser mais
en toute cohérence commencé à midi de
l'environnement j'attends le rapport du
bape
puis je m'attends pas à ce que le bape
soit favorable à gnl je vais attendre
on va même déposé un projet de loi pour
que le bape ait préséance sur les
institutions fédéral d'évaluation
environnementale alors par souci de
cohérence
on va attendre le bac le bas va arriver
on va prendre une position sur cet enjeu
là je m'attends à ce que
soit passablement sévère merci merci
beaucoup et rennes pour vos questions
c'est la fin de ce deuxième thème
prochain thème services aux citoyens
nous avons pour débuter ce thème un
citoyen à toronto à mississauga très
exactement marque gravel monsieur gravel
les chefs vous éco devrait parler des
services en français pour les minorités
francophones hors québec on vous écoute
bonsoir madame messieurs vivre dans une
minorité est un défi avec les récentes
coupes provinciale c'est devenu encore
plus difficile sur le plan fédéral s'est
pas obtenu non plus parce que le service
sont difficiles à avoir par exemple
demander à un préposé au bureau des
passeports de le rencontrer vous venez
de multiplier par dix votre temps
d'attentes
air canada avoir un agent de bord ou un
préposé qui parlent français de toronto
relève presque du miracle
malgré les plaintes les nombreuses
plaintes auprès du commissaire des
changes ne change pas ma question est la
suivante comment
et concrètement et quels outils
d'intérêt vous le commissaire aux
langues officielles pour qu'il puisse
enfin faire respecter cette loi est
donné à tous les francophones du canada
un service adéquat est équivalent aux
autres très clair comme question
monsieur vous êtes le premier à répondre
alors merci beaucoup pour la question ça
c'est un enjeu très important c'est
peut-être ça va être une surprise mais
le français c'est pas ma première langue
et je suis natif de toi et c'est grâce
une décision de mes parents anglophones
que j'ai appris le français en est une
école et mesure je fais des grands
efforts j'apprends mon subjonctif malgré
les parfaits de mes paroles j'ai
toujours essayé d'armures et m'a forcé
concrètement j'ai eu une réunion j'ai
organisé une réunion entre tous les
chefs de pratique fédéral pour régler le
problème avec les
l'université francophone je vais appuyer
j'ai fait un engagement très clair pris
cette université et j'ai proposé de
moderniser à la loi sur les langues
officielles
merci madame et oui merci monsieur le
graveur c'est une question très
important parce que c'est trop longtemps
que nous n'avons pas moderniser la loi
sur les langues officielles
on doit le faire et dont le fassions
crois parce que vous avez demandé les
réponses qu'on craque les choses que je
pense que c'est tellement breton c'est
de donner vers le commissaire de l'unc
officiel les pouvoirs de punir plus tu
pouvoir pour exiger que tous les argens
où dans le domaine fédéral présenté les
services adéquats et était égal pour
l'efs pour les deux langues officielles
dont les premières années de mon mandat
merci madame et monsieur bernier oui
merci la question c'est très important
le fédéral devrait réinvestir dans ses
champs de compétence et c'est ce qu'on
va faire pour les langues officielles et
pour les autres services que le
gouvernement fédéral offre aux citoyens
vous avez ici des gens autour de vous
des leaders de partis qui vous disent
qu'ils vont investir dans le logement
social dans la santé dans l'éducation
ce sont des champs de juridiction
provinciale et nous notre politique
c'est de respecter la consigne
canadienne ne pas s'ingérer dans les
champs de compétence provinciale est de
redonner les ressources au gouvernement
fédéral pour s'assurer de donner les
bons services en français aux
francophones à l'extérieur du québec et
on en revient aux anglophones mais aussi
les autres services que vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure un gouvernement fédéral
formé dans ses champs de merci merci
monsieur bernier monsieur blanchet vous
savez les québécois savent ce qui est
une minorité parce que même si les
francophones du québec si je peux me
permettre de dire comme ça sont
majoritaires au québec on est très très
minoritaire en amérique je suis allé en
ontario il ya des gens qui ont trouvé ça
étrange mais les francophones hors
québec et les acadiens sont nos frères
et nos soeurs francophone de l'ensemble
du continent et du canada je pense que
le commissaire aux langues officielles
pour bien faire son travail doit ramener
la notion de réciprocité
il faut que les communautés francophones
à l'extérieur du québec et les
communautés acadiennes est le même
niveau de service que les communautés où
la communauté anglophone historique est
prêt
du québec il faut que les francophones
au canada et les acadiens et le même
niveau de service que les anglais du
québec
merci monsieur blanc cher monsieur singh
oui merci merci monsieur gravel peu la
question peut-être comme vous pouvez
entendre j'ai aussi un francophone mais
je suis fortement francophile
je n'étais pas chanceuse d'avoir aucune
classe d'immersion en français mais
abandonne 1 enfance j'ai en fait j'ai
tombé en amour avec la langue française
la langue molière et je veux partager
cette richesse parce que c'est une
richesse dans ma vie dans ce qu'on veut
faire concrètement c'est de moderniser
la langue officielle de mieux financer
les services français parce qu'il faut
le faire
si le gouvernement peut faire quelque
chose je veux faire quelque chose et le
fait c'est un question du courage cette
question de volonté
on a la volonté parce que c'est
tellement important merci monsieur
cheikh monsieur trudeau merci monsieur
gravel pour votre question vous
souviendrez comme moi longtemps de ce
que monsieur ford a fait 2 qui est venu
au pouvoir de couper dans les services
aux francophones
malgré qu'ils s'étaient dits pour les
gens quand il se fait élire mais c'est
ce que ça que font les conservateurs
nous notre su défendre les minorités
francophones en ontario et à travers le
pays on va continuer de le faire
on a fait un investissement record dans
les communautés francophones ou des
communautés de langue officielle en
situation minoritaire à travers le pays
et on s'est engagé à moderniser la loi
sur les langues officielles
on comprend la lutte que vous vivez à
tous les jours et on sera toujours avec
vous merci monsieur trudeau et je
remercie surtout monsieur gravel d'avoir
posé cette question merci j'espère ça
vous a éclairé monsieur gravel
merci merci premier trio sur ce thème de
services aux citoyens monsieur singh ce
scheer et monsieur blanchet vous êtes
donc questionner et vous pouvez
interagir bien sûr on a parlé je parle
de la question autochtone on a parlé de
génocide culturel
on a parlé des pensionnats des femmes
disparues de réserve sans logement ou
eau potable alors la question est très
simple à peut pas être plus simple
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
concrètement pour améliorer la condition
de vie des autochtones comme moi j'ai
porté encore le tout bon jeu pour éviter
cette problème mais on continue quand
même
donc en fait cette question tellement
sérieuse ce que j'ai vu c'est monsieur
trudeau a donné beaucoup des belles
paroles en public mais c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils les décisions qu'il fait en privé
si le problème donc avec la communauté
autochtone c'est clair si on veut agir
dès maintenant on peut agir
donc la question c'est ça si on respect
le fait que les enfants autochtones ont
le droit d'avoir les mêmes financements
il ne faut pas les plots suis dans le
cour de justice comme ce trou d'eau à
fait ce que je fais je vais respecter la
communauté autochtone ça c'est
primordial
c'est le premier étape c'est le respect
et la dignité si on commence avec ça ça
veut dire au mieux faire des finances la
communauté autochtone avec le
financement égale très bien c'est un
débat messieurs chers messieurs blanche
à l'issue du sujet merci beaucoup
une inspectent respecter les premiers
nation c'est de respecter quand les
communautés at on dit oui dit oui au des
projets pour aider la croissance
économique
et quand on parle de communauté dans les
endroits éloignés
courage les secteurs qui créent le plus
d'emplois pour les premiers nation c'est
le secteur minière les secteurs
forestière et le secteur énergétique est
ce c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
dit que je vais à nommer une ministre
avec leurs responsabilités pour faire
les consultations dans une manière
dynamique pour assurer qu'en respecte
nos obligations communes aux gourmands
avec les traités dublanchet les
relations avec les premiers peuples sont
marquées par un déficit de confiance
parce que c'est ma compréhension
c'est la compréhension qu'on doit en
avoir parce que ce sont de véritables
nations avec les mêmes droits privilèges
obligations et responsabilités que des
véritables nations mais il ya une
déclaration de l'onu d enquête d étudier
des commissions et eudis et c'est eux
qui disent pour ce que je suis à l'aise
le dis pas ça doit venir d'eux que ça ne
vient pas une cas pas de suites
concrètes qu'on ne met pas en oeuvre des
démarches clair qu'on fait tout ce qui
est théorique ce qui est beau et puis
pendant ce temps là les solutions ne se
trouve pas le respect ne s'établit pas
la confiance ne se construit pas il va
falloir modifier une relation profonde
avec les premiers peuples en d'une
incurie des populations c'est pas un mot
c'est une réalité auxquels ils ont droit
comme nous non je suis tellement
d'accord avec ce que monsieur blanchet a
dit en fait si on part de respect j'ai
visité grassy narrows cette intimité en
trois zones et par là mercure mais
messieurs trop d'eau dans un v événement
privé elle s'est moquée de quelqu'un qui
est milité pour dire notre lot est
emprisonné qu'est ce que vous allez
faire
elle a dit merci pour votre données
c'est complètement incompréhensible
comment quelqu'un peut faire ça si on a
visité cette immunité
on a vu les impacts et l'emprisonnement
sur les corps des gens comment les
enfants et tremblent à cause de cet
empoisonnement
c'est je n'ai pas les mots peut dire
comment être quelqu un peut de dire
c'est bon si les passe quelque chose eh
bien je vais je vais arrêter le
chronomètre sur ce trio là comme vous
avez pointé monsieur trudeau sur une
question très précis je vous donne 20
secondes monsieur trudeau pour répondre
à cette question là si on peut ouvrir la
lumière de monsieur trudeau et les airs
si nous avons fait énormément pour
investir dans les communautés
autochtones à travers
le pays nous travail mais jusqu'où lundi
que la communauté de grassy narrows on a
travaillé avec travaille avec eux pour
approuver un centre de traitement et on
va donner le financement nécessaire pour
ce centre de très très bien alors vous
gérez votre votre tour je vais vous
parler de la question autochtone dans
votre trio on peut refermer la lumière
de monsieur truc dont je vous lance un
peu c'est un peu chacun là on trouve des
milliards de dollars pour acheter les
oléoducs qui on trouve pas l'argent
après des années et des années et des
années pour donner de l'eau potable à
des communautés autochtones
elle dépend vraiment de la politique
c'est fondamental c'est élémentaire un
minimum de respect et de dignité pour
des peuples qui sont autant des peuples
que nous s'il vous plaît et s'il faut
reconnaître que à peu près tous les
partis pas à peu près tous les partis se
sont succédé et et constate que c'est
très difficile de voir des améliorations
concrètes
ce chien je n'accepte pas c'est une des
filles mais c'est essentiel que nous
avons un engouement qui prend ses
responsabilités sérieux ça c'est mon
engagement pour les premiers nation on
va assurer qu'il n'y a pas seulement des
investissements mais une nouveau système
pour assurer que l'investissement
fonction c'est pas seulement une
question d'argent c'est aussi de
rétablir les dynamiques dans les
départements j'ai propre et j'ai proposé
de moderniser ce suédois ou pour les
premiers des nations alors qu'il peut
bénéficier de leurs ressources
naturelles sur les réserves et les japs
tremplin vous s'élargissent et les
ressources naturelles la clé c'est parce
que l'on sait réconcilation le créé le
problème clé c'est on a eu des
gouvernements conservateurs et les goûts
nos libéraux qu'ils ont choisi des
négligés les communautés autochtones
c'est ça ils ont eu la chance de la
faire si elle veut faire pour que
quelque chose pour le secteur pétrolier
il saute pour acheter un pipeline et ce
pour donner des milliards de subventions
c'est surtout une référence s'il vous
plaît faites et les premiers blocs ne
l'imposé pas de papa ottawa ils ont
droit de participer aux choix et aux
décisions très bien sur la fin de ce
trio deuxième confrontation sur ce thème
et nous allons poursuivre sur le thème
des autochtones monsieur trudeau
pourquoi c'est très récent vendredi
vous êtes allé en appel d'un jugement
ordonnant qui vous ordonné au
gouvernement de verser 40 mille dollars
à des enfants autochtones confiait la
protection de l'enfance vous deviez pas
être le champion justement de la
réconciliation oui et on est et on
continue de l'être
on est d'accord avec le tribunal qu'il
faut absolument compenser ses enfants et
on va le faire on va travailler avec eux
pour établir les bons niveaux mais on a
pu faire faire des investissements
concrets au cours des quatre dernières
années on a levé 87 avis d'ébullition
d'eau à long terme
après dix ans de monsieur harper whisky
a rien fait on a pu créer des nouvelles
écoles des nouveaux investissements en
partenariat justement avec les peuples
autochtones mieux comprendre il faut
continuer il y en a beaucoup plus à
faire
mais le grand chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations perry bergen a reconnu
qu'aucun gouvernement n'a fait plus
veule on reconnaît on en est plus à
faire
la négo et messieurs mais surtout non ce
n'est pas vrai parce que le trim tribune
des doigts humaine à un jugement et les
avocats de notre gouvernement votre
gouvernement a contesté la raison tant
ce n'est pas vrai que je vous avais dit
que vous avez à l'aise avec la décision
les avocats de deux hommes ont fait rire
la santé un effort de renverser le
jugement en faveur des enfants
autochtones
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour ça c'est
un vrai scandale
on est d'accord avec le tribunal qu'il
faut compenser ses enfants on encore des
problèmes ont alors pourquoi ai je suis
je sais de quoi pourquoi avoir fait
appel mais surtout parce que le
l'échéancier de le faire d'ici décembre
ne fonctionne pas avec les élections qu
on est entraîneur on découvre on en
compte lancer ses enfants mais ça prend
un peu de temps pour l'avoir de la bonne
façon chiffrement comme un problème mais
on a encore des problèmes aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de réserve tous les réserves
n'ont pas d'eau potable c'est pas une
question d'argent pour livrer ses
services live 21 milliards de dollars
que le grand fédéral dépense dans les
relations avec les premières nations
il faut changer le système le syndic ou
ne fonctionnent pas et ça fait des
années comme vous
qu'on essaie de bâtir meilleures
relations avec les premières nations ce
qu'il faut faire c'est bien clair il
faut abolir la loi sur les indiens
il faut s'assurer qu'ils aient plus
d'autonomie sur les réserves
il faut s'assurer de développer un droit
de propriété sur les réserves
il faut qu'ils avaient à richesse qui se
créent sur les réserves et oui il faut
aussi développer des pipelines pour
s'assurer en collaboration avec les
premières nations que la richesse puisse
arriver sur les réserves c'est pas une
question est encore plus d'argent de ce
match c'est une question de changer
notre relation c'est bien c'est très dur
et je le suis tout à fait d'accord qu'il
faut passer au delà de la loi sur les
indiens
mais c'est à eux de décider le rythme
avec lequel ça se fait il ya plusieurs
communautés qu'ils ont déjà fait au
travail avec toutes les communautés pour
qu'ils puissent le faire mais à leur
rythme et dans le respect de leurs
priorités
très bien je veux vous l'envoyez une
question je vais leur demander d'ouvrir
les lumières pour les six
exceptionnellement en régie parce que je
veux vous poser la question sur la
culture on l'abordé trop rapidement tout
à l'heure vous promettez un certain
nombre d'entre vous promettez sucre d'où
ça a été long mais vous l'avez premier
neuf autres dans vos engagements
d'imposer ou taxer les géants du web
vous engagez vous à remettre cet argent
aux créateurs aux artistes qui
produisent des contenus et qu'ils
reçoivent
on va se dire vision des miettes qui
reçoivent des miettes titre do
rapidement chacun on va en faire plus
que je sers cette lan en investissement
aux cultures c'est notre proposition 3%
de redevances pour imposer des
redevances parce qu'ils exploitent
commercialement des contenus qui leur
appartiennent pour 3% des centaines de
millions de dollars par année
réservé aux médias et à la culture et au
divertissement aux inconscients
forcément ces dindons 40% réservé au
secteur francophone comme ça se fait en
merci du sushi répondu j'aurais dit on a
des bons vieux on va imposer une taxe
sur les géants du web qui ramasse
beaucoup d'argent ici de notre économie
et on va assurer que cet argent va pas
propre et d'un programme et aussi on va
créer un nouveau régime pour le nouveau
à médias numériques parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui truquent réellement
nul très bien aucune retenue parce que
les gens malades
n'at-il pas verni la balance moi je dis
c'est inéquitable actuellement que les
gens ne paient pas assez grand du web
l'on ne paie pas de tps il faut qu'ils
la paient comme les autres pays qui
participent aux et l'argent qu'on va
voir nous c'est la juridiction du canada
après les crises budgétaires oui on veut
investir et bien madame et le filmeur
source de revenus pour exactement
c'est ce que vous proposez pour aider
les artistes pour donner leurs revenus
vers notre prime unité culturelle mais
je vais acheter les semences choses
parce que je seconde travaillé comme
avocat ce n'est pas vrai que le mépris
mais statique la ville du doigt et même
pour les peuples au katanga
c'est vraiment ouvert au gouvernement de
demander plus très bien monsieur blessés
des problèmes et monsieur trop d un
flash à gauche pendant la capa novateur
a dit tout ce qu'il veut mais tu n'as la
douane quand il est au gouvernement
oui il faut taxer les géants du web et
oui il faut réinvestir dans la culture
pour les artistes et pour les créateurs
oui fortement oui très bien merci
beaucoup je vous remercie de votre
collaboration
je pense est éclairant pour les gens qui
nous regardent
j'appelle patricia cloutier bonsoir
patricia qui va vous poser des questions
aux siens en rafale on va accélérer le
rythme des questions très concrètes de
les voir très intéressant patricia qui
vous rappellent j'attends des réponses
courtes 15 secondes environ
des millions de canadiens se sont fait
voler ces derniers mois des de leurs
données personnelles
êtes vous prêt à faire comme la grande
bretagne et à pénaliser les entreprises
responsables d'une fuite de données
mais ce seuil oui bien sûr les banques
en responsable des gardes et la privas
si des gens et quand on a des situations
qui arrive quand ça avec les banques ou
l'après vie c est brisé c'est la
responsabilité des banques et oui il
faut avoir des répercussions
merci monsieur trudeau oui on a créé une
charte pour la défendre les droits
numériques des citoyens on travaille
avec la grande bretagne et la france a
pour s'assurer que les citoyens puissent
avoir contrôle de leurs données
tu peux savoir le contrôle de leurs
informations merci monsieur blanchet
nous proposerons au parlement que les
sûr on va proposer au parlement d'une
part que les mesures d'identification
des clients soient beaucoup plus sévère
deuxièmement que les déclarations soit
faite
aucune fuite de renseignements il faut
que l'entreprise déclare le fuite de
renseignements à la fin de l'année
qu'elle déclare l'ensemble des futurs
dans l'entreprise et couvre les frais
qui pourrait être encourues par les
clients très bien monsieur bernier mais
oui à la protection des renseignements
personnels et aucune entreprise est au
dessus de la loi merci madame mais c'est
presque une année oui bon on doit
protéger les canadiens contre les choses
comme ça
les dogues sont négligents et on doit
protéger les droits des consommateurs
mais c'est cher mais maintenant oui on
va protéger les consommateurs les
canadiens et canadiennes et à assurer
l'intégrité de leurs données mais je
dois dire que c'est le gourmand de
justin trudeau qui a donné essayé de
donner le provisions statistics canada
pour ramasser l'information sont
concentrent des canadiens société
d'accepter canada voyons mais vraiment
les données des données financières
banquière vous avez donné l'absolution
pc seulement l'importation position les
démarches une question pâtissier xac on
n'est pas dans un moment de débat une
autre question pour vous les canadiens
attendent depuis longtemps un trait à
grande fréquence entre québec et toronto
vous engagez vous à réaliser ce projet
de transport et si oui quand monsieur
said dabach oui c'est un engagement dans
notre plateforme on a déjà engagé sadin
parce que ça touche
comment on peut faire face à la crise
climatique en investissant dans le
transport en commun
donc oui on est tellement pour la
crainte de l'être en conséquence c'est
un élément de comment on peut réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
le faire tout de suite
merci mais c'est rude autres c'est nous
qui chapeaute le projet on s'est assuré
que sa part par trois rivières que ça se
rende à à québec il ya encore du travail
à faire là dessus mais on est un
gouvernement qui a choisi d'investir
dans les infrastructures
contrairement au gouvernement
conservateur dont les provinces qui ne
veulent pas investir dans les
infrastructures merci de ses blanches et
comme ce trailer c'est le sasquatch on
en parle tout le temps on ne le voit
jamais il a été promis par les libéraux
en 2015 je me rappelle monsieur
champaigne 10 mn que salaires et à
shawinigan est là et on dit quoi cette
année on va peut-être faire une étude
parce qu'on n'est pas sûr on n'est pas
sur le board embarquer dans le train
merci
dc vernier tout le monde promet les
investissements avec de l'argent qu'on
n'a pas c'est de l'argent qu'on à pas et
c'est bien pour le dire et nous ce qu'on
dit c'est que non il faut équilibrer le
budget en premier et on ne commencera
pas à plaire à tout le monde la matière
d'avoir des votes c'est pas responsable
de vouloir dépenser des milliards de
dollars quand il ya d'autres choses à
faire pour équilibrer le budget avant
merci madame y merci les gars culte est
absolument dans notre plan une mission
possible
on doit ce père mettre sur pied un
système de transports en commune ii côte
à côte à côte particulièrement entre 30
hors québec et aussi pour entre edmonton
et calgary
nous avons un système de trois fois en
cabine qui s'est vraiment pour le
mexique
merci enfin monsieur scheer et seulement
60 % des fonds des autres organes défaut
structure ils sont dépensés sur les
grands projets oui j'ai eu une
discussion avec yves lévesque notre
candidat at revient on appuie ce projet
parce que aider dans la croissance
économique à vous rendre la vie plus
simple pour les gens de la région et on
va le faire paraître ambitieux turquie
fait les promesses mais elle brise
pourra prendre le train un jour c'est
pas tout à fait car ma prof merci
beaucoup papier merci alors prochaine
[Musique]
politique étrangère et immigration nous
débutons avec un citoyen il est à dieppe
au nouveau brunswick philippe marcil je
crois que j'étais universel moncton
monsieur marcel bonsoir à vous les chefs
vous écoute votre question bonsoir les
chefs comme vous le savez avec les
événements qui se déroulent à hong kong
l'emprisonnement des deux canadiens et
les nombreux manquements face aux droits
humains en chine
seriez vous prêt à cesser les échanges
commerciaux si la situation ne
s'améliore pas merci beaucoup pour votre
question première réponse monsieur
bernier
oui la priorité est bien clair c'est de
faire en sorte que les canadiens
puissent être retour au canada est
actuellement bien qu est ce qui arrive
c'est les relations avec la chine qui
sont terrés pas leurs meilleurs sons
peut dire mais pas seulement la chine
avec d'autres pays à cause du
gouvernement trudeau
donc ça serait une priorité comment
faire bien oui il faut avoir l'oeil de
nos alliés mais aussi en mettant
regarder nos relations commerciales avec
la chine
et ça peut être quelque chose qu'on va
évaluer pour imposer d'autres des tarifs
si jamais on n'a pas la réponse à ce
qu'on veut c'est rapatrier ces canadiens
le plus rapidement possible et aussi ce
que je peux vous rajoutez sait que c'est
important de s'assurer qu'on a des
bonnes relations avec l'ensemble des
autres pays
ce qu'avec monsieur trudeau avec les
états unis on n'est pas la meilleure
entente et avec l'inde aussi cette année
merci merci monsieur bernier monsieur
trudeau on reconnaît que la priorité
c'est toujours de défendre les intérêts
des canadiens et de défendre les
canadiens c'est pour ça qu'on a
justement fait activé tous nos alliés
autour de la planète pour mettre la
pression sur la chine pour leur dire que
non ça ne se fait pas de détenir de
façon arbitraire des canadiens pour une
raison politique
on va continuer de chercher à résoudre
c'est un jeu tout en reconnaissant que
la chine est une économie en croissance
qui prend beaucoup plus de place qui
crée des opportunités économiques pour
nos producteurs pour nos travailleurs
mais nous devons toujours être là pour
défendre nos valeurs nos principes et
c'est ce que nous allons toujours faire
merci monsieur tout dire monsieur scheer
séparer une grande surprise que le gros
match et ne respecte pas ce titre d'or
après de son voyage désastreux
beaucoup des chefs d'état du g20 qui ne
respectent pas monsieur trudeau arif
pendant neuf mois pour protéger les
canadiens et les canadiennes les
intérêts des canadiens
j'ai dit que quand premier jeu va
retirer l'argent canadien de la banque
d'infrastructures asiatiques
il y a aucun ça c'est une banque qui
était contrôlé par le gouvernement de la
chine
il n'y a aucune bonne raison pour
l'argent des contribuables d'être aidé à
l'aide pour construire les ponts et les
routes dans les autres pays et qui
appuient la politique étrangère de la
chine
on va y revenir à ça monsieur things
will à la priorité si les canadiens qui
à ce moment sont dans une situation
tellement difficile donc il faut agir
dès maintenant pour les aider ça c'est
quelque chose qui qui est essentiel en
plus ce oui la question sur qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec la chine forêts du
fort pour montrer qu'ils ont défend les
droits de la personne ce qui se passe
encore c'est tellement inquiétant le
fait que les gens à fond face des grands
auprès nations contre les 3 mai avec
monsieur trudeau encore on voit qu'il va
flasher à gauche pendant la cabane du
tout les bonnes choses mais il va
tourner à droite pendant qu'il est au
gouvernement
ce que je veux dire pourquoi elle a pas
arrêté de vendre des armes à mercy
mercier n'a pas d'amis nous avons un
éléphant dans la chambre c'est le
traître que monsieur a accepté avec la
chine c'est dont le parlement de
dernière palme ans et c'est du jamais
j'avais dont les débats de paris c'est
pas un seul vote c'est une traite ce
serait énorme avec les investisseurs du
la république de la chine qui a donné
déjà les doigts des entreprises de la
chine de charger le cadre
quand nous avons les lois que le chine
n'aime pas contre les lois pour protéger
l'environnement et c'est tout à fait en
secret c'est quelque chose
merci merci monsieur blanchet finalement
amèrement d'avoir une pensée pour les
agriculteurs sous gestion de l'offre de
la circonscription d'aller chez lippi de
la vallée du richelieu parce que de
mauvaises négociations commerciales
octv de -4% leurs parts de marché après
ça le gouvernement canadien s'est fait
l'instrument des états unis et ses
poignets une chicane avec la chine
malheureusement la réponse c'est qu'on
peut pas être chic en perpétuelle avec
un géant comme on peut pour jouer des
brocs avec la chine malheureusement
c'est impossible et je sais les
producteurs de porcs de soya et de
canola qui paie le prix de sa alors
malheureusement il faut maintenir une
relation commerciale avec la chine
j'espère qu'on pourra revenir aussi sur
un autre l'arabie saoudite le traitement
de rêve pas d'un oui la vente d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite saoudite qui choque
beaucoup de gens au québec
il faut que ça cesse merci monsieur
blanchet alors monsieur marcel merci
beaucoup de votre question et non
poursuivons sur le thème alors on va on
va poursuivre sur ce thème de la
chesnaie sur cette crise diplomatique
depuis donc dix mois maintenant où vient
de faire mention de ça il ya deux
canadiens qui sont emprisonnés en chine
en représailles à l'arrestation de même
wenzhou la directrice financière de
huawei monsieur vous voulez durcir le
ton envers la chine a imposé des tarifs
douaniers
est ce que c'est la méthode trame de
vous proposer partout c'est c'est une
contraste méthode inaction de justin
trudeau
parce que c'est clair que pendant cette
crise il n'a rien faire et il a pris
neuf mois de nommer nouveaux
ambassadeurs et elle a pris neuf mois si
seulement juste avant le déclenchement
des élections qu'il a faire une une
crainte pour la tribune au mondial pour
la caméra à dire que mon approche
on va montrer on va montrer aux le
gouvernement de la chine convainc
défendre nos intérêts on va défendre nos
producteurs agricoles et on va défendre
les chrétiens qui sont détenus une chose
je dois dire le l'excusent pendant cette
crise ne pas auprès du gouvernement de
ne pas ingérer dans les affaires de
l'exécutif de huawei c'est que le
gouvernement ne peut pas le premier ne
peut pas gérer dans une poursuite
criminelle mais prend dans la sphère des
sims et l'armée c'est justin trudeau qui
a essayé d ingérer à cesser nourrir
notre position versus le gouvernement de
la chine parce qu'on est avec trop elle
a dit quelque chose mais faire les
choses présent la comparaison
la comparaison le canada ont à peu près
le même poids relatifs à sa la chaîne
face aux états unis où face à l'europe
est toujours eu et les relations
commerciales avec l'europe ou l'asie
on fonctionnait relativement bien
pourquoi est-ce que récemment ça s'est
mis à lille tout croche
ça c'est mieux aller tout croche parce
que la crédibilité de l'interlocuteur et
ça compte la crédibilité de
l'interlocuteur n'est pas à la hauteur
du un discrédit international ce que
fait que le président des états unis
peut quitter une rencontre ni un
communiqué qu'ils étaient émis se moquer
du premier ministre du canada
je pense qu'une question de respect
qu'un pays qui est quand même un pays
dangereux doit exiger suberbie la
politique étrangère du canada doit être
doit être axée sur la sécurité la
prospérité des canadiens et j'aimerais
faire remarquer que de ce thème si c'est
politique étrangère et immigration et je
suis seul ici sur le plateau qui est
prêt à faire en sorte à dire oui au
gouvernement le goas concerne
l'immigration le gouvernement legault
veut un seuils d'immigration plus bas et
s'assurer d'avoir deux immigrants
économiques monsieur chez on veut
toujours avoir plus plus d'immigrants
est d'accord avec monsieur trudeau a350
1000 par année
il n'avait pas de solution pour régler
la route les gens qui passent
illégalement à la route roxane et ça
c'est important ça c'est pour s'assurer
sur les migrations derrière monsieur
bernier c'est clair on le sait il veut
baisser les sur l'immigration vous c'est
quoi votre fonction là dessus que j'ai
fait une grande tournée de du québec à
l'écouté québécois et dans chaque
endroit j'ai entendu la même chose est
en pénurie de main d'oeuvre
est ce que suivent les trois sites
travailler avec monsieur legault pour
donner plus d'autonomie au québec pour
les migrations et je suis le seul pour
faire et je dois dire que avec plusieurs
députés bloquistes
on ne peut pas faire parce que justin
trudeau va rester compromis avec les
sièges bloquiste ça va garantir que
justin trudeau va continuer sur le
devant je leur ai proposé ensemble
régler la situation à nos frontières
super chien va t on nous tue à voter
pour le bloc c'est voter pour les
libéraux à voter pour le bloc c'est
voter pour les conservateurs voter pour
le bloc
c'est vrai pour le québec cependant ça
va dans un parlement c'est une
démocratie première chose deuxième chose
monsieur legault et le gouvernement du
québec a demandé clairement les boues
apparition le mercredi après-midi les
pouvoirs à l'immigration la sécurité
c'est ce que vous devriez vous engager
tout le monde a compris au québec
notamment pour les enjeux économiques
zew / liga si vous aimez prétendre
d'être le meilleur ami de monsieur
record mais on est mieux ce soit net
après les réactions vous vers vous allez
travailler
monsieur chez vous tous les attributs de
bakwa le blog voici le meilleur exemple
d'une cacophonie
les gens n'ont rien sur quoi les
rescapés pour vous je suis second non
j'ai pas que ce contrat était unique tab
là dessus ce qui est à dire c'est que
monsieur scheer n'est pas d'accord avec
monsieur legault qui va avoir des
entrevues avec chaque immigrant qui veut
s'assurer d'avoir un test de valeur pas
d'accord et que sa valeur
c'est vrai et est en train de dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont régler la route
roxane vous ne réglez pas ici on veut
vraiment avoir plus d'une grande nature
économique
il faut avoir moins de réfugiés et c'est
ce qu'on veut faire on veut aider les
vrais réfugiés cool henri blanc dans
verizon sur des relais merci monsieur
bernier julie secondes monsieur blanchet
10 secondes je vais appris à utiliser
les réfugiés qui quittent la guerre
civile qui quittent les désastres
naturels par qui vit de l'état de new
york et je vais régler le fait dans le
temps de les faire appliquer les mêmes
principes dans les dents les boeufs les
endroits comme maximum on va assurer que
notre système qu'on serait votre
plancher deux choses
appliquer l'article 10 de l'entente
entre les tiers pays sûrs pour fermer le
chemin oxame et forcer les gens à passer
par les vrais procès pour pallier ces
démocraties c'est sous les gens ont le
droit
très bien autre trio autres trios mais
je signe madame et
monsieur trudeau ce truc dont on
poursuit la discussion sur l'immigration
est ce que j'ai prêt à donner les
pouvoirs que le premier du québec vous
demande en immigration
il ya l'histoire du test des valeurs il
ya aussi la possibilité de baisser les
seuils pour une catégorie d'immigrants
on a travaillé et monsieur legault a
baissé les feuilles à d'immigration
folle au québec parce que le québec a
beaucoup de pouvoirs en matière
d'immigration plus que toute autre
province et c'est une bonne chose
à cause de l'identité québécoise et la
protection de la langue est d'ailleurs
s'ils veulent appliquer un test lors du
certificat de sélection
c'est tout à fait correct et s'est
approprié qu'il le fasse
on reconnaît l'importance que le quai de
gouvernement de québec est et plus de
contrôle sur l'immigration c'est quelque
chose que nous nous avons toujours bien
travailler avec le gouvernement du
québec depuis quatre ans dessus très
bien très ouvert mais les verts nous
sommes absolument au verbe parlé avec
monsieur legault par sky news com vers
nous sommes absolument engager de
travailler avec la nation québécoise
d'égal à égal
mais au niveau fédéral au niveau pro
tour notre pays nous sommes engagés pour
augmentation des niveaux d immigration à
cause de deux choses nous avons nous
avons besoin des travailleurs et
travailleuses et en même temps nous
avons les obligations parce que nous
sommes un pays terrorisé
nous avons contribué plus que notre
nombre des populations de crise
climatique
elle nous avons le problème des réfugiés
climatiques
je me suis si oui on est prêt de travail
avec le québec c'est tellement important
on va mieux financer les mieux
intégration des gens mais quelque chose
match aller un peu monsieur blanchet a
dit voter pour le bloc ci beauté pour le
québec et ses mashaal un peu parce que
oui le bloc c'est vous
mais le québec c'est une diversité
d'opinions c'est une diversité des
régions c'est une diversité des voix dès
que vous n'avez pas un monopole sur
lequel on ne l'est pas du tout vous
n'avez pas à mon endroit qui est
d'ailleurs j'avais justement dire la
même chose parce que je suis fier
québécois et je suis fédéraliste
et je suis fier canadien est ce qu'on a
vu en 2015 c'est que les québécois ont
choisi de faire partie d'un gouvernement
et c'est ça qui a mis fin à dix ans de
monsieur harper qui n'investit pas en
culture qui coupe est partout et qui
proposait de l'austérité et maintenant
que le bloc veut reprendre une place et
vous et les québécois encore une fois à
l'opposition les québécois d'oeuvre
doivent réfléchir très très clairement
est ce qu'ils veulent faire faire partie
d'un gouvernement qui va continuer à
lutter contre les changements
climatiques à travailler maintenant sur
des priorités communes c'est exactement
ce qu'on fait depuis quatre ans est ce
qu'on va continuer dans le missile
trudeau c'est clair que vous donnent des
belles paroles maintenant mais en fait
vous êtes premier ministre de vos petits
amis vous avez rencontré des secteurs
pétroliers 1500 fois et puis après ce
n'était pas un hasard que vous avez
acheté un pipeline très bien mais qu'on
a eu on est vraiment impressionnant je
suis fière messieurs 5 permettez moi non
pas sur le sujet on était sur
l'immigration j'ai accepté parce que
l'immigration pouvoirs du québec ça a
débordé mais l'on revient pas au
pipeline mais remercie monsieur roy au
sujet des migrations
mais le monsieur trudeau vous avez fait
quelque chose que vous avez presque
jamais fait est sensé de cacher les lois
dont les projets loi omnibus budgétaire
et dont le dernier projet loi omnibus
budgétaire voudrait cacher les choses
avec un violations des droits des
réfugiés dont caché dans un projet de
loi omnibus
nous avons les choses qui arrêtait les
doigts humaine à lui les les doigts
humaines des personnes qui veut faire
chercher un vide sécuritaire et cie
opéra c'est tout à fait refermée mais
nous comprenons que les canadiens
croient qu on devrait avoir un système
rigoureux et équitable qui s'applique à
tout le monde et on est en train de
suivre toutes les normes et on est en
train en train de mener les normes à
l'international pour protéger les droits
de la personne pour s'assurer que tout
le monde qui arrive dans nos frontières
que ce soit de façon régulière ou
irrégulière passe par l'intégrité de
notre système d'immigration
on a un système fort qui continuent à
s'appliquer mais il ya des gens qui mise
sur la peur il est
vision largement pour la solution car
pour régler la problème de le traverser
la frontière et régulé ça c'est de
suspendre l'accord des tiers pays sûrs
mais vous n'avez pas le courage de le
faire parce que vous n'avez le courage
de dénoncer quelques comme trump qui met
des enfants dans des prisons ce n'est
pas sécuritaire pour eux
pourquoi nous vous n'avez vous n'avez
pas le courage de dire non à trempe de
suspendre deux tiers des japonais le
faire fut évité de parler des relations
avec les états unis parce qu'on est dans
une situation de relations
internationales et les relations avec
les américains c'est la relation la plus
importante pour un 1er ministre canadien
ou pour un pays seront nature est sûre
il vous avez l'alena dans un moment de
protectionnisme et on a pris un mauvais
départ et j'ai toujours la question
c'était le monde plein de presse sur la
gestion de l'eau la foule devait
augmenter les prix des médicaments vous
avez solution paris bercy mais ce signe
la question du second c'était le lac en
sur les tiers pays sûrs oui parce que il
s'ouvre il peut pas s'ouvrir aux
continue de le travailler avec les
américains
castonguay va se joindre à moi pour
poser des questions donc à chacun des
chefs en rafale allaient castonguay chef
du groupe politique d'une actualité au
soir bonsoir messieurs bonsoir madame
première question pour monsieur trudeau
plusieurs citoyens nous ont écrit parce
qu'ils sont inquiets et préoccupés par
la cinquantaine de migrants qui arrivent
chaque jour sur le chemin loxam à la
frontière canadienne
est ce que pour vous c'est un problème
oui c'est un problème parce que on a on
est dans un monde maintenant ou 60 65
millions de personnes sont des migrants
sondés sont des gens déplacés à on
reconnaît qu'on a une responsabilité de
passer ces gens là dedans l'intégrité
dans dans de façon rigoureuse dans notre
système d'immigration
et si ce qu'on fait on a fait les
investissements nécessaires il n'y a pas
de passe-droit à la frontière tout le
monde qui vient de façon régulière ou
irrégulière à ces vérifications de
sécurité et passe dans toutes les étapes
de notre système d'immigration
merci monsieur trudeau madame et le
réchauffement climatique est un problème
planétaire et pas seulement canadiens
dans les dix prochaines années
la chine prévoit ouvrir six nouvelles
chante centrales au charbon chaque mois
comment s'assurer que les efforts
canadiens
ne sont pas anéanti annulés par les
autres pays c'est pas possible pour moi
de donner en garantie mais je suis
absolument certain que ce qu'elle adore
reste comme maintenant comme une tour
stories et riche qui sont absolument
engager de augmenter les niveaux de gaz
à effet de serre c'est impossible pour
nous de jouer un rôle dans le monde dans
les négociations des nations unies
nous avons eu tant de temps passé le
rôle de lille
nous avons perdu ce rôle à cause de
notre absolument est un échec contre les
désastres changement climatique je suis
certain qu'avec un plein comme mission
possible
nous pouvons encore jouer un rôle comme
leader merci madame et monsieur bernier
vous souhaitez que le canada accueille
moins des migrants moins de réfugiés
vous souhaitez couper dans l'aide aux
pays pauvres
vous souhaitez vous désengager de l'onu
est ce que le canada a un rôle à jouer
dans le monde
effectivement le canada a un rôle à
jouer dans le monde avec ses alliés mais
d'abord faut aider les canadiens en
premier c'est ce qui est important
et en ce qui concerne l'immigration vous
avez raison d'en parler parce que
monsieur trudeau a laissé sous-entendre
tout à l'heure que notre position sur
l'immigration et une position radicale
lorsque 49 % des canadiens veulent un
seuils d'immigration plus bas et on est
seul parti ici qui en parle
on essaie seulement six pour cent des
canadiens veulent encore plus et plus
d'immigration
nous ce qu'on dit il faut orienter sa
sur l'immigration de nature économique
ayant un coût et un coût social avoir
toujours plus et plus d'immigration
regard des jeux sur les maisons le prix
des maisons à toronto et aussi à
vancouver et 41 % des immigrants vont
lancer grandes villes là et ça fait une
pression à la hausse sur les logements
là bas donc il faut s'assurer d'avoir su
plus bas merci monsieur scheer vous
souhaitez diminué de 25 % l'aide aux
pays pauvres ce qui ramènerait la
contribution canadienne à son niveau de
est-ce que vous tournez pas le dos à la
tradition canadienne pas du tout on va
éliminer 25 % de l'aide aux étrangers
qui à ce moment avant à l'épée
relativement avec les revenus élevés
on va garder cette oreille garder cet
argent ici pour rendre la vie plus
abordable le premier qualifié on va
payer pour notre best et pau université
850 $ pour une complète de revenir à
moyenne et on va éliminer la tps sur les
factures d'honoraires diderot et tousser
et tout ça en coupant l'aide aux pays
bas et aussi les subventions coopératif
et aussi on va avoir d'autres
plateformes tout chiffré bientôt c'est
au contraire que le che trudeau qui
cache les chiffres de plus de 50% de ses
engagements
merci monsieur monsieur blanchet vous
avez dit que le canada aurait dû se
mêler de ses affaires et ne pas arrêter
la directrice financière de huawei
wenzhou à la demande des états unis
selon vous est ce que la règle de droit
est négociable en fonction de la
puissance du client ou du pays je pense
que c'était pas simple de même
la réalité est que les états unis ont
évoqué des règles de droit qui rentrait
dans des notions de commerce c'était pas
le geste criminel c'était vraiment lié à
des sanctions c'est complexe était lié à
des sanctions que le canada ne pas
cautionner et lorsque tu embarques sur
une patinoire comme ça contre un
adversaire ça devient un adversaire
aussi puissant que la chine et que c'est
des agriculteurs du québec des
agriculteurs de l'ouest qui paie le prix
de sa de te comporter de façon que je
qualifierais d'irresponsable
on pense aux conséquences et les
américains sont pas venus aider le
canadien agit comme en rien fait comment
on fait pour faire respecter nos traités
d'extradition si on répond pas à nos
amis qui eux demandent dans le caudrésis
était traité d'extradition c'est un
enjeu d'extradition liés à des sanctions
commerciales imposées par les américains
quitte à pauli a déjà ses ailes vers six
nations je me suis blanche et monsieur
singh chaque fois que le canada singh un
accord commercial que ce soit avec les
états unis où avec l'europe
le npd s'y opposent êtes vous libre
échangiste ou protectionniste
donc pour moi cette question dès
qu'elles sortent d'un échange au moins
si la chance d'un avantage et aux
travailleurs le travail c'est bon mais
ce qu'on a vu avec monsieur trudeau il
veut avoir des échanges et aussi avec
monsieur scheer comme un conservateur
elle veut avoir des échanges qui donne
de pouvoir tout le bénéfice aux plus
riches mais sanaa est papa de tous les
travailleurs un travail ce que je veux
voir céder à cordes où on dans des
bénéfices des avantages pour les
travailleurs et travailleuses
parce que je ne travaille pas pour les
plus riches je travaille pour vous les
gens mais monsieur singh l'europe et les
états unis ont quand même des valeurs
qui ressemble au canada pour les
travailleurs pourquoi ne pas être
d'accord avec ces accords là donc par
exemple avec l'alena on a eu des brèches
dans la gestion 9
on a eu une augmentation des prix des
meilleurs s'en est finalement pas des
protections et les 100 meilleurs ou
l'environnement
merci monsieur seck merci alex est
question merci beaucoup prochain thème
[Musique]
identité éthique et gouvernance nous
lançons le thème avec une question d'une
citoyenne elle est à montréal lise
pigeons bonsoir madame pigeons
bonsoir patrice alors nous vous écoutons
les chefs vous écoute votre question
j'ai 63 ans je suis atteint de sclérose
en plaques depuis près de 30 ans et
surtout d'arthrite rhumatoïde sévère
depuis 12 ans je ne marche plus je
souffre je parle des culottes
d'incontinence j'ai des plaies de
pression et j'en passe
madame et messieurs afin de permettre à
vos proches et à nous tous un jour
d'avoir le droit de mourir dans la
dignité pas mettez vous aux électeurs
oui ou non d'alléger la loi actuelle
comme le recommande la juge baudoin de
la cour supérieure du québec
mais ce bien sûr sans créer d'embûches
supplémentaires merci merci infiniment
madame pigeon je vous reviens après les
réponses
madame et vous êtes la première à
répondre un terme aux gens je suis
vraiment touché dans votre situation et
je veux donner à vos mails sympathie est
aussi un engagement parce qu'on doit
changer cette loi j'ai fait mais ça sort
dont le parlement dont l'étude de les
projets de loi pour permettre le
les dents mur est la dignité les droits
des citoyens de choisir de façon à les
moments de mort en vérité je veux faire
encore les mêmes choses dont le prochain
parlement
merci madame et monsieur singh madame ma
réponse est oui
et merci infiniment pour avoir le
courage de partager une question assez
difficile et pour partager votre
histoire qui est aussi tellement
difficile ça prend beaucoup de courage
et je veux vous remercier
c'est clair avec le jugement au québec
que les critères sont trop limitées et
ça ne donne pas la dignité
donc ce que je veux faire c'est de en
lever les limites parce que c'est trop
limité je veux vous donner plus de
pouvoir d'avoir le droit de mourir dans
la dignité
c'est une décision difficile mais il
faut avoir accès aux ces trois
importants donc oui je suis avec vous et
oui on peut le faire
merci monsieur shing monsieur blanchet
la réponse est très évidemment oui c'est
un phénomène très nouveau c'est une loi
c'est une philosophie nouvelle au québec
comme au canada et je vous félicite et
je félicite les gens qui sont allés au
tribunal parce que vous vous êtes
emparés de cette loi là vous avez dit
maintenant c'est à nous ont aussi
participé à commence à votre vie pire
comment ça va s'appliquer
je pense que le gouvernement les
gouvernements doivent s'engager
fermement à respecter le jugement sans
condition qui est à travailler en
parallèle par la suite à continuer à
bonifier ces lois là il est essentiel
que le jugement soit respectée merci
monsieur blanchet monsieur trudeau merci
madame pigeons pour votre question et
pour votre courage d'être avec nous si
ce soir c'est une question extrêmement
personnel pour les individus pour les
familles et nous devons être là en tant
que gouvernement pour vous aider à
naviguer ces questions difficiles
oui nous allons alléger la loi dans les
prochains six mois parce que nous
reconnaissons depuis le début que
c'était une nouvelle loi un équilibre
qu'il fallait chercher entre la
protection des plus vulnérables et le
respect des droits et des choix de
chacun chacune
et on comprenait même il ya 3 3 4 ans
quand on a mené seule cette voie là que
les tribunaux la société tout allait
évoluer et nous on va évoluer avec merci
votre question merci monsieur triaud
monsieur merci beaucoup pour la question
et a bon courage à vous avez tous mes
sympathies a servi donc ça c'est l'enjeu
très pressé et je dois dire que c'est
une des moments que j'ai trouvé que tous
les partis au parlement a vraiment
essayé de trouver a le teint commune de
bonfol répondre aux allées aux décisions
de court mais en même temps on trouve
trouve hélico libre pour protéger les
régions vont sabrer les choses comme ça
et âprement nous allons toujours
respecté les décisions de court en même
temps on va faire une revue de la
décision est déterrée régime parce que
quand monsieur blanchet a dit ça c'est
vrai tellement nouveau système rigide si
aucun endroit à ce qu'on trouve de bons
voire merci monsieur chouf conclusion
monsieur bernier oui effectivement cette
fois là doit être révisée moi je peux
vous dire que j'ai voté en faveur au
fédéral de la loi sur aude mourir avec
dignité et comprendre la liberté et la
responsabilité individuelle au parti
populaire
je m'apprête re effectivement à
m'engager à regarder cette législation
là et s'assurer que les gens qui
prennent cette décision difficile avec
leur père soit capable de faire ce
qu'ils veulent faire pour leur fin de
vie
donc vous avez complètement l'appui du
parti populaire dans votre démarche
merci monsieur bernier merci surtout
madame pigeon vous êtes la plus
courageuse d'entre nous ce soir ici
merci beaucoup
d'avoir eu le courage de venir nous
parler chez que c'était pas facile
nécessairement et c'est un débat
important et qui va suivre son cours on
vient de l'entente
merci madame pigeon bonne fin de soirée
merci merci nous poursuivons avec la
première confrontation à 3 monsieur
signe monsieur trudeau et monsieur
bernie inutile de vous dire qu'on a reçu
une tonne de questions sur la laïcité je
vous repose à vous trois et je le ferai
aux trois autres la question assez
simplement allez-vous intervenir dans la
contestation de la loi 21 sur la laïcité
et si oui à quelle étape donnez nous des
détails parce qu'on a l'impression que
vous êtes tellement prudent pour ne pas
perdre de vote au québec que ça devient
tellement confus votre discours je vous
en prie soyez clair monsieur si je
commence avec vous oui d'accord j'étais
toujours clair je ne veux pas intervenir
dans je ne veux pas intervenir
est ce que je veux faire c'est de
toujours lutté contre la concept
division je suis contre évidemment
l'idée de discrimination moi je pense
que je pensais beaucoup de gens qui font
face est cette discrimination dans leur
vie c'est complètement inacceptable
mais je veux gagner le coeur des gens
donc je suis au québec je suis à travers
le pays et je parle aux gens et j'ai dit
oui parce que je porte un taux bas mais
je suis pour la loi d'avortement
je suis pour le droit de mourir dans la
dignité je sais pour la lutte contre la
crise climatique
et oui je porte un turban mais je
partage vos valeurs c'est une question
de valeurs
donc si on veut protéger la société il
faut renforcer les droits des femmes il
faut renforcer dans le droit d'abord
l'avortement
ça c'est comment on peut créer une
société plus juste et je suis prêt pour
la faire je trouve jour j'ai toujours
été clair moi aussi que nous
n'interviendrons pas à cette étape ci
parce que c'est une question où les
québécois sont en train
mettre au défi devant les tribunaux
cette loi qu'ils trouvent injuste mais
je trouve aussi que ce serait
irresponsable a pour un gouvernement
fédéral de fermer la porte à tout jamais
à intervenir dans un cas deux étapes
futures dans un cas de liberté de droits
fondamentaux
on devrait être là pour protéger des
francophones en dehors du québec
on devrait être là pour protéger les
droits des femmes les droits des
communautés lgbt ou bien les droits à
des minorités religieuses
je vais toujours défendre les droits de
tout le monde et on verra aux prochaines
étapes
mais me suis trop l'on vient nous dire
qu'il va intervenir
et puis monsieur signe que dit le
contraire de ce qu'avait dit en anglais
récemment
moi je peux vous dire que j'ai une
parole et effectivement les six mois
terminés je peux vous dire que j'ai une
parole et on n'interviendra pas c'est
une décision du québec la laïcité au
québec est un fait maintenant ça passe
c'est passé dans une législation et il
faut respecter ça le québec ses propres
juridictions le propre compétence de
passer une loi sur la laïcité et nous
nous allons la respecter nous allons pas
intervenir comme va faire monsieur
trudeau comme il vient de le dire
et monsieur 5 en anglais avait dit le
contraire c'est important le souligne
peuvent messieurs si vous aviez dit en
conférence de presse après le dernier
débat que à l'étape de la cour suprême
vous interviewez driller alors vous
préciser exactement de juger répéter
seulement un fait mais ce trou de là dit
il ya un fait et je l'a répété mais ce
que je j'ai dit clairement je ne veux
pas intervenir il y en pour suite je ne
veux pas intervenir
ce que je veux faire c'est de gagner le
coeur des gens j'ai toujours dit ça et
je veux faire ça parce que je sais que
la politique de division ce n'est pas
bon pour la société tout à fait à
l'arraché sidéré clair que une
possibilité d'une intervention
éventuelle mais c'est pas garanti
monsieur bernier parce que nous allons
laisser les étapes suivent leur cours
mais pensez-y je pense que les canadiens
s'attendent à ce qu'un gouvernement
fédéral soit là pour défendre les
communautés francophones si par exemple
un gouvernement majoritaire conservateur
de john ford s'attaque aux conso et
francophones en ontario
on s'attend qu'un gouvernement fédéral a
ancien parole pour défendre les droits
des femmes contre un gouvernement
conservateur qui récompense des prix
sera là pour défendre les droits
fondamentaux de tout le monde ce dernier
conclusion n'étions que la conclusion
est bien simple on veut intervenir on
veut empêcher et faire en sorte que le
consensus au québec qui exercent sur la
loi de laïcité ne soit pas respecté et
c'est votre position un fédéral qui vont
intervenir le gouvernement fédéral qui
va dire au québec quoi faire dans ses
propres champs de compétences et nous au
parti populaire on veut respecter
monsieur trudeau la conscience
contrairement vous on veut pas s'ingérer
le québec a pris ma décision le
gouvernement a pris une décision avec un
courage politique que monsieur legault
et le verdict est bien connu moi je
respecte cette décision là et il ya un
consensus et quand vous tirez sur
d'autres sujets je me suis je dois
toucher les droits des femmes donc c'est
un chose de dire que oui on protège les
droits des femmes l'autre chose de le
faire maintenant au nouveau brunswick
ils ont en train de fermer la seul
endroit où on accès aux services de
doigts d'avortement mais vous n'avez
fait rien pour protéger accès aux
services d'avortement au
nouveau-brunswick
comment vous pouvez dire une chose en
public oui je suis pour le droit
mais en privé ce que vous faites ce
n'est pas là monsieur trudeau là dessus
sur la dernière clinique d'avortement
effectivement prévu nous sommes très
préoccupés par la décision du
gouvernement conservateur au nouveau
brunswick qui en retour en arrière sur
les droits des femmes
on avait travaillé avec l'ancien
gouvernement libéral au nouveau
brunswick pour améliorer l'accès à
l'avortement l'on voit un gouvernement
conservateur qui s'est fait élire qui
n'est pas là pour défendre les droits
des femmes et c'est ça le danger pour
défendre les droits des phares est bien
merci beaucoup à vous deux trop deuxième
trio sur le sujet et on va poursuivre
donc avec madame aime ce cher monsieur
blanchet et je veux rapidement rester
sur l'avortement va revenir à la laïcité
mais je veux rester sur l'avortement une
seconde monsieur chère vous engagez vous
améliorer l'accès à l'avortement
malgré
vos conditions vos convictions pro vie
pour la dernière fois je vais à dire
j'ai toujours été clair sur cette
question je suis personnellement promis
mais on ne va pas changer l'axé où les
lois c'est la même chose pendant les
dernières à premier ministre libéral
constructeurs savent eux ne va pas
changer sur mon lit le chef suprême je
suis premier premier s'en va pas changer
la loi ou la xai point final voilà
monsieur blanchet je reviens vous la
laïcité et j'ai une question pour vous
et végétation pour vous et je vais
relancer le trio si la cour suprême
invalide la loi québécoise sur la
laïcité en tout ou en partie
est-ce que selon vous ça relancerait
l'option souverainiste
je sais pas qu'est ce que les québécois
ferait dans ce col haut mais pour les
québécois la notion de laïcité c'est une
valeurs progressistes héritée de la
révolution tranquille c'est généreux
c'est accueillant ces bienveillant ça
protège légalité tout le monde ça
protège l'égalité des sexes c'est pas
quelque chose de contraignant ou de
restrictif dans le coeur et la tête des
québécois
j'appris ceux qui reconnaissent que
c'est à québec de décider
je comprends les ambiguïtés monsieur
samedi vous dites dans la même affaire
en français par mag l'ailé jeunesse nous
avons travaillé sa peau de rêve d'enfant
puis quand on parle de laïcité mais
surtout nous parle du nouveau brunswick
du droit à l'avortement
les québécois sont capables d'avoir des
gens avec lesquels il repose de doutes
quant à l'engagement sur la laïcité est
ce que les gens qui se ferait virer de
bord encore une fois par la cour suprême
se dirait qu on a été comment dire
négliger eu un manque de respect
institutionnels par la plus haute
instance juridique du canada et y en a
sûrement qui se poseraient la question
mais je suis convaincu que tel n'est pas
l'intention du gouvernement le goût qui
n'est pas un gouvernement souverainiste
il ya seulement moi qui étais qui peut
être premier mais ce qui était toujours
clair sur cette question
on ne va pas intervenir un voeu pape
mais va pas c'est mon position le
premier jeu de le convaincre
c'est mon premier et mon position
rougerie et ça va être ma position après
l'élection mais c'est clair que a
la priorité de monsieur blanchet s'est
de réanimer le mouvement souverainiste
il va travailler avec le parti québécois
le lendemain après l'élection pour
relancer les débats trop pour une autre
référendum cesser son priorité ça c'est
clair
mais oui aussi je ne veux pas à traîner
mais je pense que c'est vraiment un peu
des arts dont ces élections c'est le vin
je suis d'accord avec chantal hébert qui
a écrit aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas un
enjeu dont une élection fédérale
et nous avons eu le débat au sujet de
loi 21
je pense que plus que le crise
climatique tente où cette élection pour
ça je suis inquiète je vous espère que
la lui québec quoi le québec comme
nation reste une société inclusive
je pense que c'est une question pour le
québec et les québécois et les
québécoises mais nan on situ s'il vous
plaît nous avons il reste discutée
qu'est-ce que passe pour les personnes
dans le nord du canada lactique
les personnes dont les régions
atlantiques les questions pour servir ce
n'est pas dans les débats bridge
quelques séquences sur cette loi parce
que puisque tu as dit quelque chose
tellement bizarre on parle de la loi 21
au québec et a commencé de parler d'eux
les autres enjeux de les autres
provinces et il était obsédé de les
politiques provinciales dans l'ordre de
tout l'ontario est la même mais rangé
une menace hypothétique pour justifier
son opposition et une cohérence sur cet
enjeu n'y a pas le monopole sur les
affaires bizarre parce que vous venez
dans des veines pas mal vous aussi
justin trudeau le papa de trois secondes
vous êtes en train de dire que le
gouvernement legault se fait
l'instrument d'une tactique bloquistes
qui va soutenir la loi 21 pour faire
avancer le blog que le lendemain le bloc
va aller travailler avec les morts
alors que la dernière fois que j'ai
vérifié le 21 octobre c'est pour un
référendum sa souveraineté son élection
fédérale où le bloc québécois dit aux
québécois n'en voyait pas avant d'avoir
des gens qui vont défaire ce que vous
avez demandé à ce que québec de faire
autre chose que j'ai dit c'est que vous
prétendez être le meilleur ami de
monsieur vous vous cachez vous aimeriez
vous cache vos interventions actuelles
pour une journaliste
alors pour vous pouvez réanimer le
mouvement souverainiste le lendemain
après les élections le concentré à muret
la qualité de tous les canadiens de
baisser les impôts de rendre la vie plus
abordable j'ai les doigts de palais oui
donc la question de loi 21 je pense que
tous les chefs ont le problème parce que
tout le monde dit que au niveau ferrera
sauf pour monsieur béring
nous sommes contre le voir mais en même
temps on doit respecter le québec et
l'est que les décisions de court
attendent la décision de contestation
qui sont ils en train au québec
voilà merci madame et l'on vous a
laissée par les questions en rafale
maintenant il a été beaucoup beaucoup
question de cette histoire au cours des
derniers mois sur la scène politique
canadienne
alors je vous pose la même question à
tous souhaitez vous souhaitez vous un
accord de réparation pour snc lavalin
pour que l'entreprise je le rappelle
pour le bénéfice des gens la maison pour
que l'entreprise ne soit pas obligé
d'être condamné à ne plus recevoir s'il
ya une condamnation des contrats publics
pendant dix ans premier à répondre
monsieur permis je suis nous sommes le
seul parti suis le seul chef qui a dit à
l'époque il ya aucune corporation qui
est au dessus de la loi aucune
entreprise qui est au dessus de la loi
donc le gouvernement de monsieur trudeau
1 installé dans la législation
canadienne une clause qui permet d'avoir
des ententes spéciales avec des
compagnies corrompus nous nous sommes
contre ce à tous les compagnies doit
être traité de la même façon
snc lavalin comme les autres et ça c'est
très important parce que si vous ne
faites pas ça les compagnies et les gens
vont perdre confiance dans notre système
juridique
non nous les petites compagnies sont
poursuivis lors ce qui arrive quelque
chose
les grandes salles aurait quand même
chose aussi très bien donc non monsieur
singh c'est tellement difficile de dire
ça mais c'est ça va être la seule fois
de ma vie que je suis d'accord avec
monsieur bernier mai mais dans ce cas
oui il fallait un dernier débat
mais ce que je veux dire c'est oui c'est
que là le résultat de ce qui s'est passé
monsieur trudeau à essayer d aider les
indécis pdg pas des travailleurs
travailleuses ce qu'elle a dit en fait
elle est un premier ministre et ses
petits amis et rencontre les compagnies
et les aides
elle peut les appeler et 10 et des mois
et dit oui qu'est ce que vous voulez
moi je suis pour les gens je vais
travailler pour les gens je veux
travailler pour les travailleurs
travailleuses ça veut dire on a un
système juste ce qui est juste merci
monsieur trudeau presque tous pays
alliés en europe et ailleurs aux un
système d'entendre de réparation qui
permettent à une compagnie de payer des
pénalités de changer son comportement
sans punir les travailleurs qui n'avait
rien à faire avec les décisions des
hauts cadres
c'est une situation qui protège les
travailleurs quand il ya de la
malfaisance au niveau d'une compagnie
c'est un système qui fonctionne à
travers le monde
mais la décision que si ça va être
donnée à une compagnie au canada
appartient uniquement au procureur
général et à au ministre la justice
il nous allons respecter cette décision
quand elle sera prise
monsieur blanchet et beaucoup de choses
à réparer dans l'entente de réparation
il faudra réparer le mépris de monsieur
trudeau pour les institutions qui a fait
planter une
démarche théorique fonctionner même s'il
est exact que les grands pays
occidentaux en général ont de telles
ententes de réparation à même leur
propre législation
il faudra réparer la mauvaise habitude
là je vois que monsieur bernier s'ajoute
à ce que monsieur 5 s'ajoute à ça de
jouer le québec corrompus les 3400
employés de snc lavalin actuelle et la
direction actuelle de livres de sensi la
vallée n'ont rien fait de poids correct
les actions tombe les morceaux vont être
vendus les travailleurs se cherche des
jobs et c'est un autre fleuron
d'ingénierie québécois qui va tomber à
cause de l'incurie ou de la mauvaise foi
des parties fédérer merci monsieur
blanchet monsieur une fleuron de notre
essai l'indépendance de notre système
judiciaire et justin trudeau est cédée
ingéré dans le décision indépendant de
son procureur écran et n'a pas obtenu le
résultat de décisions claires buzz lui
est là lui congédié il a essayé d âge et
j'ai et nourrir notre système
indépendant judiciaire la décision doit
rester avec le procureur et c'est pas
les excuses des excuses des emplois ya
sûrement une jambe qui le premier se
veut sauver et c'est là la dulwich à
vienne l'ancien merci madame madame mais
oui je suis avec mon collègue mais je
suis d'accord avec monsieur bernier a
aucune corps apparaître aucune
entreprise ni personne n'est au-dessus
de la loi
et c'est pour ça que je suis déçu avec
messieurs trop tôt parce qu'il est brisé
la loi avec le pression contre nature
procureur général et en même temps le
même projet loi omnibus que j'ai parlé
longtemps l'autre section c'est dans le
même projet omnibus budgétaire où ils
ont changé le code criminel pour aider à
cesser les relents ça ne sonnait pas de
façon merci mais les décisions merci bad
as me remets débat ouvert et comment je
vous lance une question et ensuite les
réponses sont à vous bien sur sedar
c'est dans les crises qu'on mesure le
jugement et la transparence du chef vous
avez
touche où à peu près tous dû passer
l'épongé sur des candidats dans certains
cas vous avez dû renvoyer les candidats
embarrassant à partir de maintenant est
ce que vous nous dites que c'est
tolérance zéro pour un candidat ou un
député et éventuellement pour toute
remarque qu'ils seraient jugés racistes
monsieur blanchet bon je comprends très
bien pourquoi cette question là hélas
aujourd'hui s'il n'importe lequel des
candidats qui ont été mis en cause avait
refusé de s'excuser de façon explicite
il ne serait plus candidat du bloc parce
que je peux affirmer et je suis
convaincu que mes énormes réseaux
sociaux mon passé de chroniqueurs vont
passer aux ex tous ont été souscrites et
personne ne peut douter que je souhaite
non importe quoi qu'ils soient un petit
peu proche de raciste je n'aurais eu
aucune espèce de tolérance et je
comprends que les collègues et fait la
même chose dans un certain nombre de cas
dans ce qui me semble essentiel dans une
campagne électorale c'est que les gens
choisissent pour qui ils vont voter en
fonction des valeurs qui vont être
portés et c'est de ça dont il faut
parler de nous de tout coeur
on va travailler pour lequel a vu quatre
exemples des gens qui ont dû s'excuser
monsieur chier aussi monsieur trudeau
aussi monsieur chira l'isi je peux vous
dire qu'il ya une candidat qui n'a
jamais être passé de notre système notre
processus pour analyser les crânes et là
c'est le candidat qui a brisé la loi sur
l'éthique deux fois c'est une canada qui
a monté souvent qui a bondi de 2
beaucoup des choses dans sa vie et ça
c'est le candidat libéral de papineau se
trudeau les excuses sont importants mais
les jets stylisé intentions et les
valeurs sont importantes aussi on va
toujours jugé selon kelly priorité les
valeurs et les actions de tous et de
chacun
ça fait partie du choix électoral que
les gens font est ce que les gens
représentent leurs valeurs et son heure
pour les dix défendre et je pense que
les gens savent que depuis quatre ans je
les défends et on va continuer d'avancer
en les défendant ne sommes pas parfaits
je ne suis pas parfait des candidats ont
fait des erreurs
l'important c'est que les candidats
assument ces erreurs là et si au lieu à
des excuses oui c'est parfait mais après
ça après ça on doit s'assurer que ces
gens là partagent les valeurs
canadiennes les valeurs d'équité de
liberté de tolérance et c'est ce qui est
important pour nous notre parti est
fondée sur des principes clairs l'équité
la tolérance et le respect et on veut
nos candidats fassent la même chose et
ils le font très bien monsieur singh
donc c'est en fait c'est une question
d'authenticité
donc si quelques s'excuse mais il ne
s'engage pas d'échangé pour l'avenir il
n'y a pas un engagement fort et faire
des choses différement dont non mais si
c'est un sac qui s'excuse et aussi un
engagement d'échangé est aussi en fait
six cas qui partagent nos valeurs
on va rester dans la partie nos valeurs
c'est de travailler travailler pour les
gens pas pour les produits
nos valeurs sont de travail pour
défendre droits de la personne nos
valeurs sont vraiment avancer la justice
sociale en même temps qu'on combat
contre la crise climatique
on peut le faire ensemble c'est
exactement les sortes candidats équipe
on a et c'est exactement ce final inédit
en ont besoin
nous avons un problème dans notre de
marcos et j'ai plusieurs gens qui me
demandais pourquoi que quelqu un qu un
citoyen va représenter pour un parti
dont notre démarque aussi dans les
élections parce qu'il ya toujours les
choses qui sont intéressés mais pour moi
même c'est une question les niveaux de
leurs commentaires
nous avons dont le parti vers zéro
tolérance vers racisme et antisémitisme
sexisme
c'est clair mais on doit réfléchir parce
que 16
l'action dans les dernières quelques
semaines nous avons approprié le temps
la grande majorité du temps avec les
petits politique pas dans le dialogue
pour aider tout le monde de trouver les
façons de travailler ensemble contre un
jean slim à tickets avaient jusqu'à
mardi dernier souffle je vais travailler
ensemble il faut qu'on fasse un bon
choix faut qu'on avance pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques et on
va continuer merci monsieur schirrhein
petit mot monsieur blanche un petit mot
et nous conclut ensuite alors le choix
cette élection c'est clair ces quatre
autres années avec les hausses d'impôts
la vie qui devient plus cher ou une
pratique considérée avec moi qui me
rendrait bien que le marché 10 secondes
pour saab au parlement on votera pour ce
qui est bon pour le québec pour votre
compte qu'ils m'avaient pour le québec
merci lire pour le biais mesdames et
messieurs merci madame mais sur les
chefs qui merci à vous dans l'ensemble
vous avez été disciplinés merci 21
octobre jour du vote mesdames et
messieurs c'est un rendez vous donc pour
la grande soirée électorale sur toutes
les plateformes de radio canada
merci de votre attention merci à toute
l'équipe derrière à la prochaine